visión está comenzando todos los asistentes están en modo de solo
escucha que hay bastantes preguntas o comentarios en el
Discord creo que también ha habido alguno por por e-mail.
Bueno, podéis usar la
camino que queráis, pero es verdad que el Discord pues tiene la
la ventaja de que primero puedes interactuar y es así.
De vez en cuando os comentáis cosas y
es un tema interesante, gente que aporta cosas y además pues
es público y todo el mundo lo ve, entiendo que alguien a lo mejor puede
querer pre-vacidad por algo, pero pensar que casi seguro
la duda que tienes también la tiene alguien más y al final
nos vamos a ayudar un poco entre todos y es interesante, creo que es interesante
hacerlo en el Discord, recordar por si hay alguien todavía que no tiene que
nos pide que el Discord podáis
o que va por invitación es público, pero si que hay unos canales que son
reservados a alumnos y para para poder verlos sí que tenéis que pedir
unos acceso para que os demos acceso.
Alejandro Escalzo no sé si está por aquí, si está por aquí que hable en el chat
por favor, porque me habla siempre del Discord, por aquí no te tengo fichado.
No sé si es que no no pasas por los directos, pero
pero me escribes mucho en el Discord, es que el que más escribe
y está muy bien, pero pero digo que también si estás por aquí pues también
identificate, vale, vale.
Venga, voy a ir respondiendo un poquito
cositas que habría que había en el Discord
bastante interesantes. Bueno, ya que he pronunciado tu nombre, Alejandro,
la verdad que tú me ponías ahí un sistema con la información que me das me
resulta imposible decirte, darte una opinión, me has puesto ahí unas
unas capturas del rendimiento en sí, pero no me pones la pantalla
y ya me respondes lo del Mar Magnifer y yo iba un poco por ahí, no te lo quería
decir, pero iba un poco por ahí, pero cuidado porque es que aprovecho para
comentar eso, aquellos que no estáis viendo el Discord,
esto está en el pregunta aquí, está en el pregunta aquí, justo al final
Alejandro había puesto ahí unas pantallas y él mismo se cuestionaba
como que algo no lo veía claro porque lo veía demasiado bueno, entonces
bueno, cuando te pasa esto normalmente hay truco, normalmente hay truco,
pero bueno, a veces también hay cosas muy buenas, pero muchas veces hay truco,
es decir, al final esto suele salir con colaboración preliminar,
por lo que habíamos insistido mucho en eso, ver gráfico, ver gráfico,
pero justamente ahí Alejandro no me había puesto lo que para mí en esta etapa es
más importante ver el gráfico, porque ahí al final puedes ver si hay esta
trampa, esta trampa en el sentido de que hay un error de lógica o que el sistema
no está reproduciendo bien el pasado, recordar que cualquier optimización
simplemente trata de reproducir, trata de simular lo que habría ocurrido,
pero nunca lo va a conseguir exactamente, es muy difícil.
De hecho, para hacerlo habría que hacerlo con lo que entre session se llama
look inside bar back testing en multichart se llama bar magnifier,
pero habría que hacerlo tica tica y tica tica, normalmente no tenemos muchos años,
normalmente tenemos seis meses, es complicado tener una base de datos muy
larga tica tica, entonces es muy difícil hacerlo tica tica
y por lo tanto a veces recorremos a hacerlo en un minuto por eso,
porque sí que en un minuto tenemos muchos años y nos es más fácil,
pero hay veces que en un minuto no es real tampoco
y por eso a veces no pasa, yo lo he visto, yo lo he visto en sistemas de que en un
minuto no estaba reproduciendo bien, entonces en este caso el bar magnifier
también tendría trampa, pero de todas maneras
de todas maneras aquí ya comenta Alejandro que al activar el bar magnifier
pues se ha dado cuenta que ya había fallo, por lo tanto, de momento,
de momento por ese lado, por ese lado, le voy a le voy a poner,
porque yo no sé si es que no lo sabe, que estoy en direct, estamos en la clase,
estás en la clase, estás en la clase ahora,
a ver si me contesta por el disco, porque yo me parece que no, pero bueno, en fin.
Vale, había alguna otra cosita, en este
y en este mismo hilo había puesto
José Donet que también había enviado algún mensaje,
justo lo estábamos mirando eso antes de venir, no sé si a Alberto le has
contestado por email, me comenta Alberto que te ha mandado un email,
parece que no estabas, seguramente no estabas actualizando bien la
reinicializando, perdón, la variable y entonces claro no actualizaba el valor,
entonces te quedaba con un tráil en la mejora antigua o alguna cosa,
entiendes, por eso te pararía más caro.
Cuando usamos variables, esto ya es tema de programación, es básico
reinicializarlas y a veces nos pasa a todos,
se te olvida, nos pasó también en un día, es decir, que no es algo que sea raro,
no es algo que sea raro y es importante porque si no,
claro, no va tomando el valor a cada nueva barra, se queda pillado en una antigua,
en otro trade, por ejemplo, y de ahí seguramente te venían esos
errores de que no te, de que decías que el trailing te perdían mucho más del 20,
que a veces puede pasar por un gap, pasa de hecho, pero claro, si ves que siempre
pues seguramente hay un problema del código,
seguramente en este caso hay un problema de código.
Luego también había habido un debate bastante interesante
sobre el sharp negativo y esto sí que era
bastante tema de la teoría y quería, quería aclararlo,
preguntaba a alguien qué significaba, si teníamos el negativo, le contestaba
otra persona que no podía ser más que si en el numerador era negativo,
esto es cierto, pero cuidado, el numerador recordar que tiene dos,
dos datos, de acuerdo, el numerador, voy a quitar esto ya,
el numerador, aunque nosotros por simplificación,
porque no se va esto ahora, hola, ahora se ha colgado,
por simplificación nosotros a este valor le ponemos cero,
este valor es el que resta de sharp, es el valor que,
a ver, tengo el circulito este aquí,
esto aquí en el interés, de acuerdo, esto es lo que se resta de sharp,
recuerdo recordar que conceptualmente tanto sharp como sortino,
lo que miden es el retorno y por encima de la tasa libre de riesgo,
y esto lo dividen en el caso de sharp por la desviación típica de todos los
retornos, en el caso de sortino por la desviación de los retornos negativos,
porque considera que los positivos con buen criterio, mi opinión,
no tienen nada de malo, entonces él estima solo la desviación de los
negativos, esto es lo que hace sortino, entonces, pero en ambos casos en el
numerador, si tú pones aquí un 2%, él te lo resta, entonces,
que te estaba pasando, seguramente,
seguramente,
dónde lo planteabas esto, a ver, aquí en el disco para leerlo exacto,
ahora no te encuentro, es que sabíais cómo he respondido en dos sitios de sharp,
me he respondido como en dos sitios y ahora no encuentro el otro, a ver,
bueno, pues no me encuentro, me quedo con esta.
No, no, no, no hace falta, así, tiene razón, se puede buscar ahí.
No, sharp saliendo aquí, no podemos ver estos aquí.
Si es verdad, se va de coña.
Mira, perfecto, si buscas ahí sharp, ya te sale.
Si le ponía el ejemplo y aquí le contestaba Alejandro.
Este es el inicio del tema que preguntaba que...
Todo venía de la pregunta de...
no sé por qué no me sale el nick entero aquí ahora aureli no se tengo el disco como medio
colgado es que no me lo no me lo pone entero pero aureliano bien preguntaba que qué niveles de
char son buenos o malos y qué significa un sharp negativo de entrada cuidado con los sharps en
general los ratios recordar que dependen de una temporalidad normalmente siempre nos gusta
anualizar los datos y el que estás viendo tú en el entre sesiones mensual vale verás ratio
muy bajo pero es mensual es mensual es lo mismo que el anualizado vale ahí tenías uno teníamos
un antes de 0 3 por ejemplo vale 0 3 y de 12 pero tres mensuales he dicho no sé sería por
raíz cuadrada de 12 es un 1 por ciento también tiene un 2 por ciento vale sí sí sí entonces
ahí aurel y qué problema gracias que veo que esas hay la conversación exactamente aurel y era
gracias bueno es un poco jaimito el disco es público lo puedo enseñar a que la clase lo voy
a enseñar venga ahí estoy entonces venía aquí la pregunta a la pregunta de aurel y preguntaba
esto del bueno es lo que te decía que estás viendo entre este son tú que luego lo lo planeas
planteas aquí el otro ejemplo donde enseñas la curva de acuerdo y luego es hombre la curva está
bien no está bien pero tengo un ser negativo vale si la curva está bien pero la curva no
está normalizada de acuerdo es decir el hecho de que la curva gane dinero está bien pero
cuánto dinero es la izquierda que ya te nota que es muy poco vale entonces al final ahí puede ser
que sea por un tema de gestión monetaria incluso que te estés exponiendo muy poca cantidad vale
pero si tú le restas un 2% mensual le estás metiendo un palo un palo bastante considerable
entiendes si le pones cero verás el ratio de shop lo que yo en el curso llamaba bruto no sé
cómo le llamaba el curso pero bueno nosotros solemos trabajar eliminando la tasa libre de
riesgo ya os lo comenté en el curso poniendo cero para para emitir o omitir este factor y
ver el retorno del sistema partido por la desviación por la volatilidad de los retornos
de esa manera no se ve alterado por es igual de acuerdo porque no depende del tipo de interés
conceptualmente tiene mucho sentido porque yo al final le quiero pedir a cualquier inversor que
rinda más que la tasa libre de riesgo entonces por eso es está puesto así pero ya digo le ponemos
le ponemos cero entonces ahí radica eso que seguramente te estabas exponiendo muy poco y
si lo apalancas más a lo mejor ya le da para dar negativo entonces te daba negativo porque
aunque los retornos son positivos aunque sean poco positivos le estás restando mucho de la
tasa libre de riesgo y por eso te da negativo pero es interesante comentarlo porque había
habido ahí bastante bastante de bato bastante de debate no hay sobre sobre el tema y quería
saber y el mochandón y todo bueno bueno entonces esto es esto por un lado de charp vale vuelvo
aquí a las preguntas había también lo de josé ya estaba también que era esto que comentaba de
el trailing también comentaba que en cortos que no sé si estaba haciéndolo bien o que no le
encontraba nada a ver tal como hemos planteado este sistema no sé cuántos habéis trabajado
intentaba trabajar el corto nosotros también lo hemos intentado aunque ya teníamos bastante
idea que iba a pasar lo que ha pasado pero bueno así pues hemos hecho una prueba para verificarlo
efectivamente en cortos es muy complicado sacar algo en esta en esta configuración recordar que
estamos yendo en acciones que todavía son más tendenciales en términos generales que el índice
tienen más desviación son más volátiles que el que el índice por lo tanto dejan correr tienen
colas más largas dejan correr más lo bueno y lo malo es decir para subir y para y para bajar
también son más más abruptas y y es es complicado en todas ellas de manera general encontrar algo
que funcione en cortos simplemente entrando con un doncha y saliendo con esto porcentual o con
un trailing de más es complicado es complicado si a lo mejor venamos reducido la cesta acciones
podríamos haber encontrado algo sobre optimizando pero así no es es difícil hasta sobre optimizando
porque la muestra es muy variada y al final por eso estos son pruebas muy buenas en el sentido
de que las reglas que encuentran probablemente son robustas de acuerdo porque lo estás probando
en muchos activos que lógicamente tienen correlación entre ellos pero no todos como ya vimos de acuerdo
no todos así que normalmente se encuentran cosas interesantes muy difícil en este set up encontrar
cortos de acciones veremos algo en el curso al respecto a seguro en la práctica veremos algo
en corto en la renta variable pero no será con un con un canal de doncha que lleva quizá un poco
de retraso de acuerdo un poco de retraso en cortos en acciones hay que buscar cosas
bastante rápidas de acuerdo bastante rápidas con mecanismos de entrada que disparen muy pronto y
doncha no acaba de encajar con eso doncha no acaba de encajar con eso es un mecanismo de entrada
más bien lento que sí que lo puedes poner en una vela no entonces pero bueno ya entonces no es doncha
es mínimo del día que tan puede valer pero pero no es doncha como tal no no es doncha como
tal entonces es complicado en un en un doncha en acciones en tiene acciones a la vez meter
encontrar estrategias de cortos rentables pero bueno quería que os enfrentarais a hacerlo a alguien
lo ha intentado por lo menos porque me lo ha comentado y cuando os diga esas cosas probarlo
porque porque es como más se aprende es como más se aprende salen dudas que las luego las
ponéis en el discor y ya mantenemos una conversación de ello entiendes y al final es un poco lo más lo
más interesante vale si hay algo relacionado con lo que digo ahora de las preguntas sí que lo
comentamos abierto por por ir cerrando vale si tienes si tienes relación con lo que estoy
diciendo ahora que ya es una pregunta pues vamos cerrando el tema vale como por ejemplo aureli
cosas que tengan que ver con lo que hemos hablado sí vale este era otro tema este ya me lo ha
cerrado ya me lo ha cerrado alejandro el mismo carlos rola no sé si está en el chat no sé qué
artículo te refieres ya me lo aclarirás te lo he preguntado ahí y luego también tenía alejandro
aquí otro caso del gol forward que explicará bueno como ya haremos gol forward como tal el
gol forward de multichats a mí no me gusta nada vale tiene la ventaja que es muy rápido vale pero
no me gusta nada o sea su interface no me gusta me gusta mucho más el de tres pero es mucho mucho
mucho más lento es bueno no se puede no se puede tener todo pero este sí que lo voy a dejar porque
vamos a hacer lógicamente durante las prácticas casos de gol forward completo sí que te diría y
también en la otra clase que hubieron dos tres personas que opinaron pero son muy pocas para todos
los que sois os recomendé y aquellos que no lo hayáis hecho lo vuelvo a hacer que veáis el directo
en la clase de robotraider de ivan sherman que está aquí que yo estaré creo que en abril ahí
robotraider dando mi ponencia y esto es bastante interesante y él por ejemplo en esta ponencia
comenta que él no es muy amigo del gol forward y quería pues salir un debate ahí sobre sobre el
tema pero el gol forward para mí a mí sí que es importante y sí que me gusta pero tampoco
es la parancia universal es decir a este sistema de acciones no le hemos hecho gol forward de acuerdo
y no todo esto se lo digo más ahora hablando por alejando porque todo lo que me ha comentado y
enseñado es siempre gol forward está bien que el gol forward lo pases pero el gol forward esto
creo que lo quedó claro la teoría pero la clara ahora es una prueba de estrés de acuerdo es una
prueba de estrés que hay otras hay otras y pueden valer otras acuerdo pueden valer otras pero esta
es una de ellas entonces no quiere decir que obligatoriamente tengamos que elegir parámetros
con gol forward de hecho sólo comenté es una opción es una opción que puede valer en algunos
casos y en otros no pero no es siempre el camino mejor y no tenéis que siempre ir a buscarlo es
que no vale la pena pero que no vale la pena y que el camino podemos decir convencional de
optimización convencional puede dar un buen resultado entonces por ejemplo ahí van comentaba
él que él le gusta más el hacer pruebas de validación moviendo la base de datos haciendo
pruebas de validación y luego ya la selección de parámetros hacerla con una optimización
convencional bien nosotros la selección de parámetros de todos los sistemas que operan
ahora también están hecha por convencional aunque hayan pasado gol forward no es obligatorio
entendemos al final no el gol forward es una prueba de estrés hay otras pero esta es una y ya está puede
usarse o no vale para gol forward pero no nos quedemos en que el gol forward ya se acaba la
vida es una herramienta sin más entonces ya te digo es alejandro para cuando ves la clase porque
me parece que no estás por aquí ya ya haremos gol forward y hablaremos más en profundidad de él de
todas maneras sí que aclaro teóricamente que anchole tono anchole a mí sí que muy claramente
muy claramente prefiero no anchole pero siempre que se pueda a veces el número de
trates no te va a permitir hacerlo entonces mejor hacer en ese caso probar a hacerla anchole pero
mejor pero insisto que aquí te veo a ti como muy que comparo como muy el objetivo es que
es estresar la estrategia y ver qué robusta porque al final tú le la sometes a cambios
constantes de parámetros y a cambios del corte del histórico del in-sample a lo que equivale que
la estrategia ha operado en muchos mercados sito cuando hablamos de la cláster que es la que a mí
me gusta la cláster la de la de un único la de un único cláster por entendernos lo que
sé 7 runs y 20% a mí es así que me parece que tiene cierto peligro o sea y sí que entraría
un poco en el discurso de iván y otros autores en que defienden que es muy fácil que en el fondo
puedes estar sobre optimizando pero en la cláster no no lo compro para nada en la clase no lo compro
para nada porque justamente lo que haces es todo el rato mover la ventana recuerdo mover la ventana
porque mueves tanto lo el número de rams vale el número de rams que sería esto el número de
de filas no tenemos aquí como el proceso el porcentaje auto sample que puede ser 5 10 20 30 lo
vas moviendo entonces eso que provoca que todo tu histórico quede cortado distinto entonces la
fortaleza de esto es muy alta y tú pasas la prueba por esa por esa versatilidad el sistema
ese es el objetivo solo ese nada no no hay otro acuerdo no es ni comparar ni no comparar si es
el sistema pasa la prueba o no la pasa ese es el principal objetivo una vez ha pasado ese ya
veríamos vale esta de las divisas también de aurelí cuidado a ver si a ver mirar vamos a ver no
lo tenía preparado pero seguramente abrir en un en un momentito a ver a ver cuidado porque ahí la
comparación que estás haciendo tú me da a pensar que no tenemos que hablar lo que es sedencial
es decir si yo si nosotros miramos renta variable ahí lógicamente en términos generales con alguna
excepción bueno con si miramos acciones con muchas excepciones pero en términos generales
lógicamente en renta variable tenemos una tendencia alcista de acuerdo porque porque al final las
empresas recogen los beneficios que van ganando y una empresa está hecha para ir ganando cada vez
más dinero es su es su es su sentido su sentido de existencia por lo tanto es normal que es su
tendencia a largo plazo sea siempre subir siempre es momento es porque caen bueno caen porque el
mercado se exceden cosas porque las empresas se ven mal pero su su lógica empresarial su lógica
de existir al igual que la de los seres humanos es vivir reproducirnos etcétera y al final un día
pues morimos pues no es lo mismo al final su sentido es crecer crecer ganar cada vez más dinero y
por lo tanto sus continuaciones tienen que ir al alza vale lógicamente hay empresas que les sale
mal tienen que cerrar pero se van a tomar bien bueno esto es apelé entonces claro aquí tú tendrás
tendencia alcista pero cuando hablamos de que un activo es tendencial o no estamos refiriendo eso
si tú miras un gráfico de largo plazo en las divisas normalmente no vas a ver tendencia
no vas a ver tendencia
la actividad este matín que es la primera vez que
no es así yo les he reservado un curso de potrería y van a hacer algo
de la creación
de la práctica
la situación de normalidad
de la teoría
a ver que Wospice tenía yo el curso que pueda venir bien para esto tenía uno de
la análisis de las tendencias ya no sale por eso
tendencia en futuro sería este no si bueno comentaba alberto que es verdad es un tema
que no es en absoluto menor de hecho casi que es perfecto vale ya debe estar exportado
que ahora me ha saltado un aviso de un indicador porque tuve que estar todo un día
y parece que no lo importe igual ya está exportado alberto es el abre lo 10 tendencia
en futuros 10 tendencia en futuros demandas yo voy a buscar él en la carpeta que tenemos
el easy language que yo creo que debe estar exportado que debe estar exportado no lo jodas
pues no tenemos ninguno habrá que hacerlo pues no sé qué dirte aquí está la teoría
normalizado está aquí dentro bueno ya lo haremos ya lo haremos está haciendo al mismo
momento era el mismo que la tierra normalizado pero haciendo la suma con que se ve que no
lo tenía exportado a mitad grande si si si no está importando uno a ver si era ese
pero no no sé no sé sigo preguntar cosas en fin no se me extraña pero bueno no lo
veo bueno lo voy a poner sin sin el normalizado y lo vemos para que lo mueva aquí lo muevo
aquí y así lo vais lo vais viendo si si que lo tengo igual lo ponemos es igual 14
10 si que si que tengo adx con histórico pues no sé era era era otro sí que tengo
adx con histórico alberto no sé cuál era es la verdad no me acuerdo tengo adx con histórico
lo tengo oído no no adx con histórico no sé no sé que no sé qué tienes la verdad
no sé qué pasa mensual para ver más datos y tres entonces aquí tenía yo el forex
strength vamos a abrirlo rápido bien entonces aquí tenemos el indicador ahora muchas divisas
no no sé ya yo creo que el que me has hecho ya lo tengo el otro no me acuerdo que era
esta gracias si pero es que si ya lo tengo ese no sé que era la verdad que era era ponía con
porcentaje luego luego lo miramos entonces vuelvo al tema de las divisas abrely comentaba alberto
con buen criterio que al final el hay que tener en cuenta que en las divisas siempre cotiza una
contra otra y una divisa principal y una divisa secundaria y justamente por eso tienden en largo
plazo a moverse de manera lateral vale pero aún así hay bastantes divisas que son bastante
tendenciales pero si tú miras un gráfico mensual como te estoy enseñando ahora normalmente no te
lo van a aparecer normalmente no te lo van a aparecer y los datos pues te van a salir como
ves ves 18 18 que van a salir bajos porque es verdad al final se mueve mucho el rango pero es
verdad que en el diario entre diarios comprimiendo con más pero es verdad que generalizar ahí quizá
me excedí un poco me acudí un poco en en en ser tan tan categórico de acuerdo porque las hay
más tendenciales que otras acuerdo normalmente las que tienen que ver con el bien suelen ser
más tendenciales como el dolaría por ejemplo y fíjate en diario te está dando aquí 29
normalmente las que tienen pero aún así también se mueven en rango no pero dentro de cómo ves
colas bastante tienen tramos de tendencia bastante potentes de acuerdo nativos bastante
tendenciales euro dólar no lo es mucho vale no lo es mucho pensar que normalmente en términos
generales esta es una regla bastante bastante que aplica también bastante general pero cuidado
porque cuando uno habla mucho al final se puede sustituir de más de equivocarse pero creo que
esto lo voy a decir bien vale contra más grandes el activo es decir contra más grandes un índice
normalmente más centrado está en las divisas pasa igual cuando tengas divisas más grandes de
mayor tamaño de países o economías más potentes normalmente van a tender a estar más controladas y
a moverse más el lateral por eso por ejemplo el sb 500 pues tiene menos volatilidad que la que
la saca aunque también hay un componente del tipo de acción pero es así normalmente los índices
centran las cosas vale contra más y las small caps se mueven más tienen más volatilidad que
las mid caps y que las blue chips de acuerdo por por eso mismo por contra más grande más
importante es en términos generales suelen tener más menos menos volatilidad y la volatilidad
suele tener relación con la tendencialidad entonces ahí qué pasa normalmente las divisas no tan
importantes o más secundarias suelen ser más más volátiles es verdad que las divisas cualquier
país hace submarinos de bolsillo que dice cuál es la divisa pequeña no entre estas ninguna entre
esas ninguna porque estas son las 28 más grandes que hay vale entonces sí que las hay más importantes
que otras pero son las 28 más grandes entonces pero pero hay muchos pares de acuerdo hay muchos
pares lo que pasa que normalmente admiramos las típicas pero hay pares hay pares loquísimos de
rublo no sé cuántos hay y de países exóticos hay pares de divisas cuando hablamos de divisas
es un tema enorme esas son las 28 más grandes entonces ya os digo sí que se mueven en lateral
en un gráfico mensual pero muchas tienen bastante tendencialidad en diario y yo os recomiendo que lo
lo exploreis pero claro si tú miras un gráfico de equity pues siempre vas a ver la misma tendencia
en el largo plazo ahora si lo miras en entraría ya no ves lo mismo de acuerdo es decir al final
el plazo cambia con cambia mucho el tema de acuerdo y y con tendencialidad yo me refería
es a la capacidad de operar sistemas tendenciales vale más que al hecho si sube mucho baja mucho
vale creo que habrá quedado habrá quedado claro si existe manera pregunta aureli si existe manera
de analizar por folios de divisas en por folio maestro pues entiendo que sí no porque no ahora
mismo porque no se va a poder sí sí claro cargar cargarle un proveedor de datos de divisas y punto
en por folio maestro perdón perdón por folio maestro por eso estaba estaba pensando por folio
trader pero sí que entiendo que sí de hecho lo hemos hecho en el pasado ahora la verdad que ahora
hace tiempo que lo hago pero pero si no alberto no hay ningún no no sé si si lo dices por algo
por defecto sólo deja esperate yo es que hace tiempo que no lo pruebo ya te lo digo
pero es para mirar un momento rápido eso me cuesta más bien poco por cierto ligo con un
comentario también del disco para que alguien me decía que maestro era de pago maestro está
incluido para aquellos que tenéis cuenta también os digo que no esperéis mi queridas de maestro
es decir maestro es un programa muy potente en sí pero es tremendamente lento de acuerdo
es tremendamente lento porque porque es muy antiguo entonces no hay manera que lo evolucione
yo creo que lo tienen abandonado y puede ser que a lo mejor ahora que dices desde que sacaron
claro no te deja que vale desde que sacaron bueno pero ponle equities y esto al final lo que te
marca es el tipo de activo si tú le cargas una símbolis que tengas divisas no te va si
pero era con futuro está por ejemplo a ver si ves me lo ha cargado no sé qué va a hacer
no me lo ha llevado a tomar viento pues tienes razón pues pues desde que quitaron el forex aunque
los gráficos se pueden ver por eso nosotros lo habíamos hecho en lo bueno de hecho ahí tienes
una lista hecha lo habíamos hecho cien por cien pero claro ahora hace tiempo que no prácticamente
ya te lo comentaba a ver ahora que le he puesto equities no no parece que no parece que no parece
que no parece que no pues parece que no parece que no sé si ya digo antes se podía pero pues
parece que no se puede ya bueno aprovecho que alguien preguntaba que si no se podía en maestro
en maestro usar que era de pago en discord y no ya le he comentado que no me consta y yo creo que
no aquí le enseña la captura de pantalla que tienes que a lo mejor por algún motivo lo tienes
activado mejor una fonda a la cuenta no sé no sé el tema pero no no se paga el principio esto no
se paga a la estrategia perdón esto sí sí perdón perdón perdón perdón perdón perdón perdón que
esto lo comentaba desde el discord que lo le vamos a subir un rato digo pues ya lo pongo que la clase
os dije lo del código a ver ahí os lo he dejado en documentos está subiendo también lo ponen
el disco luego lo ponen el disco luego lo ponen el disco pero bueno ya los que estáis aquí pues
lo podéis descargar desde ahí de documentos puedes descargar desde ahí desde documentos
acuerdo es aquí mismo del interface del go to webinar la clase lo podéis descargar ahora es
el código en easy language de la parte que hemos hecho hasta ahora de la parte del canal del ruptura
de acciones vale vale creo a ver aquí en el discord no no puede dejar perfecto perfecto vale
perfecto no puede verlos en directo pues nada aquí ya estaba bueno los ratios de
charlo que te comentaba a ver a nivel de anualizado que ligaba antes con el mejor
dejado y a nivel de anualizado a partir de 1 no pues se considera un ratio de sharp válido
2 pues bastante potentísimo y esta sería un poco pero anualizado anualizado recordar que para
anualizar esto lo vimos en la clase pero si es mensual multiplicas por raíz de 12 vale si
es mensual el dato es mensual por raíz de 12 es el dato es semanal por 55 semanas no son 52
perdón 52 semanas y si es diario depende de 252 o 360 es un poco dependiendo del tipo de
dato que sea el tipo de dato que sea pero esa es la manera en que anualizamos un dato diario
o mensual de si tú tienes un 0 3 por ejemplo no 0 0 4 0 4 0 4 lo multiplicamos por raíz de 12
nos haría 139 acuerdo 139 0 4 mensual sería uno 139 anualizado entonces ese es el dato de
vigilar el tema en las periodos en los periodos vale aquí atrás que ya había hecho todo lo
que comentamos a los perfectos vale esto también aureli que es en los dos personas más más activas
del disco parece fantástico tenemos ahí aureli y alejandro compitiendo compitiendo ahí fiel con
fuerza para copar el número 1 de post en el canal de disco final del curso de mosso
premio entonces se comentaba en esta pregunta que ya le esa mira me la iba a dejar y justo es la que
dije que le contestaría vale que parece muy interesante este comentario lo que decía bien
hablabas de que lo probamos en una sección pero que no necesariamente las tenemos que operar en
ese que lo que estamos haciendo es probar el sistema crearlo confeccionarlo analizarlo
evaluarlo pero luego ya lo montaremos para operar y que dije que podrías operar las
10 más capitalización vale y que él comenta que esto no tiene nada que ver con el desempeño del
sistema no viene a decir que por qué no porque elegir esas y no otras y porque no elegir en
base al desempeño bueno no no quise dar a entender que obligatoriamente tienes que ser
las de más capitalización de acuerdo es verdad que el volumen es un tema es un tema a mirar es
verdad que para nosotros como siempre aspiramos o pensamos en estrategias que tengan gran capacidad
operativa para poder operar millones siempre sin querer pues nos vamos un poco a esa esa idea pero
no es para nada obligatorio no es para nada obligatorio puedes buscar otro criterio pero
sí que en todo caso no sería solo el de rendimiento pasado aureli vale no sería porque entonces
estarías cayendo un poco en sobre optimizar lógicamente lógicamente entiendo que tú me digas
oye pero es que hay 10 que va de lujo bien está bien pero no sólo metería esas no sólo metería
esos porque siempre hay que pensar en el error en el riesgo de solucionación acordaros que he
insistido mucho en que la certeza certeza no la vas a tener nunca vamos a tratar únicamente de
acercarnos lo máximo posible y de ir al mercado con una estrategia que digamos oye yo creo que
esto es robusto firmemente pero hay que pensar siempre en el error hay que estar pensar siempre
en el riesgo y por lo tanto si tú te has equivocado y vas a las 10 que más ganan probablemente te
la pegues entiendes entonces no elegiría sólo las que las que más ganan no elegiría sólo las
que más ganan pero sí podrían estar esas de acuerdo si podrían estar esas vale pero en todo
caso momentos momentos distintos nosotros probablemente elegiríamos las demás capitalizaciones
pero por lo que en parte por lo que te decía antes de acuerdo en parte por lo que por lo que
te decía antes por capacidad por mejor ejecución mejor slip page etcétera pero bueno entiendo que
no necesariamente tiene que ser ese el criterio aurel y el desempeño sí podría si podría formar
parte de la decisión lógicamente lógicamente ahora veríamos ahora vamos a ir al sistema
otra vez ahora vamos a ir al sistema vale y luego otra vez esta ya era la de alejandro con el tema
de la optimización y ya estaba me había saltado eso no me había saltado a esa se vale creo que
estoy al día si alguien no le he contestado algo por favor que me lo diga que me lo diga aquí me
has marcado vale interesante interesante si bueno va un poco ligado con esto la comentó ahora que
lo podíamos dejar al final también pero mire ya que estamos en preguntas comenta juan manuel si
un mismo sistema con iguales o diferentes inputs se operan en corto y en largo por separado se debe
contar como uno o como dos sistemas entonces por folio da igual o sea lo puede yo lo contaría como
lo contaría como dos porque nosotros los trabajamos como sistemas independientes y también te digo que
ya sabéis que trato de explicaros lo que nosotros hacemos pero también otras cosas hay cierta
controversia ante esto es decir hay gente que defiende que los demás tienen que ser lado y
largo y corto iguales y que eso si no es robustes es verdad que lo es es verdad que lo es que si no
es robustes pero si tú puedes trabajarlos por separado por número de tres por aplicación
estadística a priori es mejor sobre todo en equity sobre todo en equity porque lo que
comentábamos en un sesgo al alza es muy difícil que un sistema vaya igual a los sistemas que van
en largo en acciones pueden ir en el corto pero no igual de la no con el mismo setup este caso de
don chan habéis visto muy claro es muy fácil que funciona en el largo pero muy difícil en el corto
muy difícil porque el corto pues tiene una pauta de volatilidad de manera de moverse muy distinta
entonces es complicado conseguir que funcione de acuerdo tú puedes tratarlo como dos como dos
pero a ver si al final si el sistema tiene los mismos parámetros entonces el mismo no sabemos
de acuerdo si si es como dos es porque tiene parámetros distintos en alguna configuración
distinta y puede ser puede ser que en uno le pongas filtro al otro no puede ser que sea parecido no
que el core sea el mismo imagínate este en el que hablamos del don chan y que para el largo lo
operes con sonido se me oye a no no el que me he quedado soy yo soy yo porque si me has
cortado el cable ahora ahora ahora puede ser que le pongas filtro volatilidad para ir largo y para
el corto no le pongas o viceversa entonces puede tener alguna pequeña variación de acuerdo que
le añadas alguna regla extra en el lado corto en el lado largo puede puede ser el primer core no
nosotros por ejemplo familia nemesis familia arte misa familia apolo bueno puede ser que tengan
algunas dentro de la familia pues haya pequeñas variaciones para el largo para el corto sobre
todo sobre todo en equity de acuerdo en acciones sobre todo gente a variable a desalvamos de las
divisas bueno son un poco más simétricas también las commodities lo que menos simétrico es es las
acciones por lo que os decía no porque al final por propia definición pues tienden a subir
tienden a subir mucho entonces claro tú pones cualquier acción pues cualquier acción que haya
normalmente normal también y bueno pues claro ha subido ha subido un poco y claro ha subido un
poco entonces casi cualquier acción que lo pongas tiene ese es bueno vale venga vamos un poquito a
ver a seguir con el con el tema vale ya os comenté que de hecho teníamos tenía un vaca y que teníamos
un pequeño pequeño vago en las formas que llevaba multichars están pensadas para sistemas
individuales y a nivel de porfolio no funcionaban igual entonces hemos hecho que hemos hecho las
nuestras directamente directamente calculadas por porfolio tanto lo que es sortino ajustado
acordaros que os hablé de sortino de sortino ajustado que era con esa corrección de dividirlo
por la raíz cuadrada de 2 vale porque para hacerlo comparable con sharp y upi vale que
es el ulcer performance index que al final es una especie de sharp con ulcer en el denominador vale
ulcer en el denominador que ya os comenté en la teoría que ulcer me parece muy muy interesante
sortino está muy bien es decir no si no tenéis más que sortino pues sortino vale entonces al final
hicimos bueno lo que ya hicimos el otro día pero mejor hecho os lo voy a enseñar ahora para que
entre todos me digáis que tengo un botón de datos aquí un poquito esto lo tengo que borrar y así
va a ser más sencillo encontrar lo que necesito esto como lo hemos hecho el multichar es lo que
os decía al final en algunas cosas fantásticas y tiene otras pues que no lo son tanto y por
ejemplo a nivel de porfolio bueno a nivel de porfolio y a nivel de optimización normal también
no te deja hacer como entre ese son un periodo en sample y un periodo auto sample en la misma
cosa que es muy práctica pero pues no te deja entonces lo tienes que hacer tú que no es lo
mismo pero a nivel de análisis ya te ya te sirve ahora que me ha pasado no te creo vale entonces
bueno nosotros simplemente hemos recogido a ver cómo me lo puedo montar esto aquí hemos hecho el
periodo en sample hemos hecho el periodo auto sample y hemos hecho el periodo all data que
los tenéis aquí la semana pasada ya vimos un poquito esto pero recordaros teníamos datos
de up y negativos no teníamos sortino y ahora pues ya tenemos todos estos datos hechos para que
juntos podamos tomar una decisión mejor es lo que os decía aquí no vamos a hacer no vamos a hacer un
como el forward vale porque además con una cartera de múltiples activos es muy muy complicado en un
sistema que opera realmente tampoco uno de los problemas que tiene el world forward es que cuando
corta y es justamente los detractores dicen eso muchos programas de hecho ninguno de estos dos lo
hace cierre la operación no hace mal tu mar que entonces claro si te dejan un trade abierto se
tiene cuenta entonces en ese sistema eso es muy crítico porque es de muy largo plazo puede estar
meses con una operación encima tienes muchas acciones distintas empiezan en fecha distinta es
muy complicado hacer un world forward riguroso en este en un sistema que lo vas a pasar en las
100 acciones entonces al final no vale la pena y además como os digo no nos hace falta nos hace
falta es decir realmente tenemos una cantidad de información que nos puede permitir considerar que
el sistema es robusto sin hacer sin hacer world forward en este caso entonces la optimización grande
aquí recordar que inicialmente os plan perdón perdido el audio hola vale vale bien bien pues no
sé no sé no sé vale bien aquí hablamos os he hecho las las dos cosas otra vez para que veáis
la diferencia de acuerdo porque quería y ahora ya tenéis ahí el documento bien y quería generar
un debate interesante sobre esto y que os quedará realmente claro para pasar al siguiente vale
inicialmente hicimos como hablamos en la teoría de hacer la optimización paso por paso de acuerdo
primero per canal vale luego hemos hecho el trailing y luego en vez de hacer el filtro sólo he hecho el
filtro con él con el aterra esto es interesante para ver un par de cosas pero también os digo
que ese sistema con dos si tú tienes dos inputs con sólo dos normalmente vas a poder hacerlo en
una porque porque a ti el mapa el mapa ya te va a salir con dos bien y a ti el mapa te da mucha
mucha información visual y no tienes ahí mucho riesgo de caer en sesgos o sobre optimizaciones
es verdad que en el fondo teníamos tres tres variables pero si tú empezabas sólo por el canal
de esta manera nos hemos dado cuenta claramente que ya se veía un poco que el canal no es perdón
un momentito pienso por la 4 vamos a ver las de sortino ya ya está nivel de optimizaciones
no es la 3 perdón y claro tengo una cantidad de optimizaciones aquí cosecho que no tiene ningún
tipo de sentido en el canal que vemos cuando vemos una variable sola quería enseñaros lo por
esto lógicamente el aspecto visual es muy sencillo de interpretación vale simplemente tenemos una
variable contra otra de acuerdo aquí tenemos el net profit pero podemos ver un din no trae el net
profit y tengo el costum fins baro tengo los dos lógicamente bueno lógicamente tienen como
veis una absoluta correlación es decir al final quiere decir que el riesgo está bastante igualado
de acuerdo pero es el tema perdón perdón es la 2 es la que os quería enseñar ahora sí venga
hablando del stress ahora sí ahora sí ahora sí esta sí sí justamente ahora vamos a la otra aquí
vemos simplemente que dejando bloqueado en 20 en 0 20 el trailing vemos que el canal tiene poca
influencia de acuerdo vemos que tienen muy poca influencia en net profit aún tiene un poco aunque
fijaros la escala cuidado con la auto escala que esto en los mapas es muy importante y es un motivo
por lo que uno de los cambios que he hecho no sé si os habéis fijado es en reducir un poco la escala
que justamente en el disco le sugería eso alejando cuando preguntaba que le salía un dato demasiado
a lo mejor a veces hay que quitarlos porque a veces están saliendo buenos porque son malos
de acuerdo porque por ejemplo tienen muy pocos trades entonces hay que hay que siempre analizar
bien a los datos y tener claro que que a veces tienes que eliminar una parte histórica en este
caso por ejemplo el otro día estábamos haciendo desde 1 hasta 20 algo y final hasta más arriba
aquí hemos empezado en 5 porque porque los de 1 a 5 no me interesan no me interesan rompen
el concepto del don chan que yo busco si yo lo miro en el gráfico de acuerdo aquí me doy cuenta que
no me sirve ese tipo de estrategia de acuerdo no me sirve ese tipo de estrategia bueno no me sirve
no es lo que yo estoy buscando de acuerdo bueno a ponerle aquí 5 donde se va a ver muy bien es en
el canal más bien al final el que gobierna directamente la estrategia siempre el trailing
el canal tienen bastante relativa poca influencia y por eso veis luego lo veréis en la múltiple que
se verá muy claro es muy estable fijaros en el ratio de custom fitness tiene poca influencia
tiene poca influencia sí que baja un poco más en los cortos pero a partir de 10 se estabilice
casi no cambia nada da lo mismo usar 10 11 12 13 15 que 20 más son nada lo mismo pero me
entendéis tiene muy poca muy poca mejora o el programiento en cambio en el otro es todo
lo contrario es el ejemplo la que os estaba enseñando antes que ahora vuelvo a ella es
el contrario el trailing pero aquí dices bueno oye parece que cada vez es mejor ya pero es lo
que os decía de la trampa antes con los trades si yo lo llevo hasta arriba cada vez va a ir mejor
cada vez es mejor pero me va a hacer menos operaciones y esa es un poco la trampa por eso
cada vez va bajando bajando fijaros cómo baja linealmente a medida que sube el parámetro
y ordena por el input y es totalmente lineal a relación con 0 10 5000 trades con 0 24 1300
si le pongo 0 35 200 trades hace 206 con 100 acciones que eso no es nada entonces hay que
vigilar porque nos podemos hacer trampas esto ha hechicido mucho en la teoría y esto donde lo
vemos lo vemos aquí lo vemos en el gráfico de verdad que ya lo comenté también la teoría es
una cosa que me choca de algunos colegas que a veces que me dicen que no miran gráficos de verdad
no lo entiendo no entiendo porque los datos son muy tramposos a veces sino no les ponemos contexto
si yo esto le pongo ahora un trailing de 0 30 un canal de 20 vas a ver las operaciones que os hace
en apple es que no hacen no sale nunca le pongo 0 40 y me pone largo desde el siglo 14 eso es lo
que queremos hombre esos vayan hold entonces al final cuidado porque podemos caer no es lo que
queremos entonces hay que buscar un equilibrio entre significación lo que ya hemos comentado
muchas muchas veces entonces tú decides tienes que dirigir un poco la optimización vale ese
concepto lo hablábamos mucho cuando elegía los parámetros acordáis la teoría y decíamos es
importante fijarlo limitar y controlar los parámetros tanto los incrementos como los
rangos a esto este es un buen ejemplo de eso de decir bueno yo decidí cortar en 0 24 creo que
fue pero 24 ya está hasta aquí no no lo llevo más no lo quiero llevar más arriba porque si no
al final sube sube sube y ya está desde si no me interesa me interesa vale bien estos datos
los tenemos todos por separado a ver ya todos todos los excel y así los vemos también el
del filtro que era la que os enseñaba antes que era el 3 está el filtro le hemos hecho
enseñando sortino solo vale para no enseñar las ya digo lo hemos hecho con un pico ni con sortino
esta sí que la el filtro solo lo hemos hecho con filtro y con trailing vale lo hemos hecho con los
dos porque porque poner solo el filtro era un poco era un poco pensaba que sólo tiene sólo le he
dejado hacer 4 4 variaciones de acuerdo sólo le he dejado hacer de 0 5 a 2 si no recuerdo mal
a ver que lo miro es 0 5 a 1 y medio vale de son 4 4 combinaciones entonces hacerlo solo pues
no te queda mucho sentido entonces prefiero combinarlo con el trailing porque como ya ya
hemos visto el canal es poco sensible canal es una variable que en este caso trabaja poco
es realmente la que la variable más directora o que más marca el rendimiento del sistema es
el trailing en este caso y aquí pues hemos variado con el trailing y como veis la única
conclusión que sacas es que el 0 5 que el 0 5 implica cuidado aquí porque es contraintuitivo
0 5 implica que actúa mucho vale implica que actúa mucho el pese aquí que de pronto 0 con
0 va desde 1600 straights a 5400 vale y en mil que en 0 5 va desde 1300 a 600 de acuerdo es
realmente donde implica una mayor actuación es decir el filtra mucho straights en 0 5
vale filtra mucho aquí ya vimos que era 0 o 1 ya os lo comenté pero bueno para poder analizarlo
y poderlo ver pues prefería hacer esta pequeña variación de hacer 0 5 vale y ver un poco se
acero que es sin filtro 0 5 ya veis 0 1 es donde están ahí en 2 también es en a partir de 2 bueno
en 1 y medio aún tiene bastante actuación en 2 prácticamente equivale al 0 ya es es no
os acordáis esta es la regla de la volatilidad la regla de la volatilidad yo creo que al final
en uno para lado largo funciona funciona bastante bastante bien vale bien y en esto
pues al final hemos traducido en estos 4 exces que rápidamente os voy a enseñar ahora y luego
enseñaremos trabajaremos el que es al final lo hemos recogido en los 4 exces como ya sabéis
haciendo este análisis que os enseñe que hacíamos siempre este perfil de optimización
os acordáis aquí que hemos hecho hemos recogido loopy el sortino el recovery que
simplemente del profil partido por drawdown y hemos hecho estos variaciones que vimos
que hacíamos en la teoría y una suma corrup y una suma sin rop ahora profundizamos en
y esta estadística descriptiva que salía de excel os acordáis que ya sale desde aquí de datos
análisis de datos eso es bastante útil ponerlo debajo de aquí esto es bastante útil porque al
final te da valores de media de mediana de moda de la kurtosis te da la desviación máximo mínimo
y a partir de ahí pues puedes hacer estos cálculos de variación de simplemente normalizar las
variables porque cada una tiene un rango de actuación y con esta división las normalizamos
simplemente dividimos cada valor le restamos del máximo y lo dividimos por él no es más que hacer
no es más que hacer el porcentaje que varía respecto al máximo es decir cuánto cae cada
variable respecto respecto al máximo cada una al máximo valor que ha alcanzado aquí de esa
manera la normalizamos también podría hacerse en algunos casos no hemos hecho fijar ese valor
de acuerdo ese valor ese valor de máximo aquí lo puedes tú limitar para compararlas todas igual
esto a veces ya cuando para elegir ese por ejemplo pues imagínate que tienes distintas
optimizaciones en todas ellas pones el mismo máximo para que el valor que salga aquí de media de suma
y demás pues sea comparable entre todas ellas porque al final este máximo depende de este excel
solo imagínate que en otro excel alcanzado 0 7 pues el cálculo será sería justo hacerlo en
todo sobre 0 7 pero bueno esto es sólo en el caso de que por algún motivo sea muy distinto
este valor máximo vale para hacer esta división que hacemos en estas en estas columnas de acuerdo
que son en las que tenéis el colorín vale que aquí hemos hecho net profit upi sortino ajustado y
recovery repito la variación respecto al máximo vale simplemente es esa ese cálculo la variación
es este varía menos 0 51 por ciento este menos 0 0 2 por ciento este menos 0 51 por ciento y así
vale de tal manera que si ordenas por el de mayor a menor vais a ver que el que queda arriba del
todo es el mejor net profit que lo tengo marcado en azul al igual que se ordenó aquí por bar upi me
va a quedar el mejor lila es el que tiene mejor upi igual que aquí se ordenó por bar sortino
arriba me va a quedar el que tiene mejor recovery 237 y así sucesivamente de acuerdo el barro me
va a quedar el que tiene mayor ropa cuidado el ropa aquí lo hemos calculado nosotros lo hemos
calculado nosotros porque como al final no nos al final no como digo multichars no nos da todos
los valores pues simplemente con los días que hay en el inci los días que hay en él en él en el
auto sample hemos calculado que el retorno nos da en un periodo y que retorno nos da en otro ya está
pero simplemente ha anualizado de acuerdo es decir dividido por 365 multiplicado por los días y
dividido por 365 que no deja de ser hacer una especie de regla de tres una especie de regla de
tres de que por ser insap tienes cuatro metros en dos días en un sample tienes 1300 días pues
pues una de tres de que tiene que ser comparable el beneficio de uno y de otro y eso al final pues
se da por detalle de acuerdo por detalle de net profit de un periodo respecto al otro comparado
por día por año da lo mismo que al final se simplifica pero esa es la manera de hacerlo
comparable recordar que el robustness index o wall forward efficiency en algunos programas de
wall forward lo que hace es comparar el beneficio anualizado del periodo alto sample con el
beneficio anualizado del periodo in sample por tanto porque tiene que ser no lo podemos
compararlo a pelo porque lo que gana en un sample es en un 30% del tiempo en este caso y lo que
gana en sample es el 70% del tiempo lógicamente las magnitudes en sí no son comparables hay que
ajustarlas por el tiempo casi todo como los ratios y todo pues lo tenemos que normalizar
o estandarizar a un periodo y eso hacemos aquí por eso hemos calculado nosotros directamente el
robundes ya que no nos da multichars vale y con eso pues hemos sacado aquí pues nuestros ratios
de suma que no deja de ser un que parámetro equilibra mejor en todos los ratios no es más
que eso es decir porque al final hemos hecho 1 2 3 4 y el rob 5 de acuerdo sería el quinto entonces
pues cada input pesa un 20% de acuerdo es decir hacemos una una media de estos
estos inputs de acuerdo que podrían ser otros al final normalmente esto si son buenos ratios
os van a dar aquí hemos metido un sortino que depende de la volatilidad de los retornos negativos
en el numerador todos son muy parecidos un recovery que depende del drawdown a pelo del
drawdown máximo a pelo vale un upi que depende del drawdown y del tiempo que dura el drawdown
vale y para meterle el retorno a pelo también hemos metido el retorno directo para quitarle
un poco de peso porque había mucho peso porque estos tres ratios al final están muy gobernados
por el riesgo entonces también hemos metido el net profit a pelo vale para que también aunque
eso se ha metido en el profit estaría bien solo estos tres también cuidado no estaría mal no
sería mal y habría algún pequeño cambio pero no no sería muy significativo de acuerdo esto al
final simplemente marca cuáles son los 10 mejores aquí vale los 10 mejores es no quiere decir que
los 10 son los que se han operado vale ahora luego lo vemos eso bien entonces que esta era
la opti 1 que acordaros que es la completa de acuerdo está así que ahora se voy a enseñar el
gráfico en el mapa en 3d esta esta es la que mide todos los ratios o sea todos los cuatro perdón
las tres inputs tiene 1200 combinaciones de 5 a 24 el canal de 0 a 1 y medio el filtro atr variando
0 5 es solo 4 y el trailing de 0 10 a 0 24 variando de 1 1% que nos da 15 combinaciones total 1200
esta es toda ella en sample ya que se nos ha olvidado el problema abierto vale bueno aquí
también la hacemos pero si no nos vemos no nos vemos porque estoy yo que está jugando con él
y me lo he movido aquí tenemos en sample el alto sample y no nos data claro lógicamente
lógicamente lo que añade capa de robustes y es interesante es que estos datos sean similares
que no ocurre del todo aquí de acuerdo no ocurre del todo aquí decir aquí cuando
orleramos por suma en in sample estamos viendo 0 5 1 0 5 1 1 1 bueno sé que hay un podemos decir
un predominio de uno pero aparece bastante el 0 5 de puesto aparece bastante el 0 5 si que el
canal esto ya lo hemos comentado antes hay una cierta aunque el predominio de zonas altas hay
un poco de todo porque al final el canal lo que hemos dicho no es muy director y sí que vemos en
in sample se habla ahora un trailing que mayormente se va a la zona alta vale mayormente se va a la
zona alta como ya lo habíamos visto en el análisis solo por daros que iba a los ratios para allá pues
bueno también en el conjunto aparece igual lo que ocurre que si analizamos en el auto sample
donde vemos alguna variación ahí vemos que sí que el trailing que es el más conflictivo parece
también ir zona alta es decir por eso bien vale bien esto el trailing también se va en la zona
alta también se va en la zona alta pero vemos que el canal se nos va más a la zona baja este
es el principal cambio entre in sample y auto sample en esta aquí se nos va a la zona baja ahora
luego vamos a ver ella solo a ver si pasa lo mismo porque esto es las típicos de preguntas que nos
tenemos nos tenemos que hacerlo y en principio esto no es preocupante porque ya es lo que hemos
visto antes en el análisis solo que no vamos a volver a ver lo que me estoy anticipando que
no es muy director este parámetro de acuerdo es muy en todas las zonas va bastante bien de acuerdo
así que bueno pues le ha dado aquí pues perfecto pues muy bien pero pero no no es tampoco tremendamente
crítico de acuerdo no es tremendamente crítico y de hecho si vemos aquí las los valores que nos
da en cuanto a profit pero si aquí arriba estamos 99 100 y vamos bajando y estamos en 80 60 70 50
lógicamente y en los ratios en esta suma aquí la suma fijaros que el que da menos da menos 1 26
la suma de todos estos ratios vale pero fijaros que no es muy abrupto se va oscilando bastante
llega a doblar al final casi llega a afilar bastante aproximadamente la mitad está bien
es bastante progresivo es bastante es bastante progresivo lógicamente en el old data el old
data al final es todo el periodo junto y esto porque alguien creo que lo había comentado el
último día y ya voy ligando así o en el disco creo que la auror y también que comentaba si
donde era tenía más sentido elegir los parámetros donde tiene más sentido elegir los parámetros es
en el old data en el old data pero habiendo mirado también que ha hecho un sample y que ha hecho
es decir no quiere decir que ignoremos los otros datos pero la elección o sea al final recordar
que la lo mismo que decían los robunes todas las la mayoría de trabajos que hacemos no son para
elegir sets no son para elegirse de acuerdo vale al final al final el el que ya lo diré el que
la mayoría de procedimientos que hacemos son simplemente para evaluar la estrategia es decir
para considerar que la estrategia es apta para operar vale y cuando llegamos a esa conclusión
entonces elegimos set vale pero no elegir set es al final todavía no hemos ni hablado de ello
entonces pero sí que lo haríamos en old data si consideramos que la estrategia es robusta que nos
gusta para operar solo eso que tiene un rendimiento aceptable mínimo etcétera etcétera tiene un
perfil de riesgo que nos gusta etcétera pueden haber muchos motivos que nos lleven a no operar
o si operar esa estrategia pero de momento evaluaríamos simplemente evaluaríamos simplemente
la la idoneidad de la de la estrategia bien de momento por lo que os digo esta comparación
entre in sample y auto sample si que corrobora bastante que el trailing va en esta zona pero
hay esa ambigüidad en cuanto al filtro atr sí que en el auto sample se va claramente al uno
pero es que todas las primeras son 111 hasta llegar bastante abajo vale cuando en el in sample
pues no estaba tan claro digamos que hay más partida en el old data usando los dos también
aparece el 1 1 y medio pero en general claramente el 1 claramente con lo cual sí que ahí parece
apuntarse que el 1 es el que más claro y aquí fijaros que en el old data en el canal pues
aparecen los dos lados aparecen los que salían más en el auto sample y aparece que salían más
y se mantiene ahí muy alto entre él lo quiere muy alto muy alto esto ya nos dice una cosa de
no es tampoco muy buenas señales no es muy buena señal porque porque que nos está indicando hay
que hay que hay que ir aprendiendo a leer a leer las optimizaciones a leer las que lo hicieron de
lo que nos están diciendo que nos está diciendo que no quiere salir que veía yo aquí estaba la
si yo le pongo aquí 024 veis que aún tarda bastante en salir pero va saliendo va saliendo
algunos casos vale pero fijaros que la mayoría de veces aún me entra más más más caro con
alguna excepción importante que esas son las que le cuestionan los que le permiten habrá alguna
excepción muy muy importante como esta recuerdo que ya justifica seguramente toda la todo esto
pero es que los stops como ya sabéis ya os he comentado muchas veces normalmente lo viene
a aportar mucho al sistema de términos de retorno pero sí que en términos de riesgo vale pero aquí
que se tiene cada vez lo que era mayor quiere decir que no es una salida muy eficiente de
acuerdo decir cuando tú tienes este tipo de mapa os lo digo esto vamos a abrir esta está en las
dos la vamos a abrir en el opti 1 en sortino no esa no es perdón yo sabrón data sabrón data
para trabajar con toda la base de datos opti 1 el data y opti 1 y aquí está son las son las dos
a ver si puedo de alguna manera no voy a poder esto bueno lo podemos poner así no se nos va a ver se
nos va a ver a esta es el que me asegure el nombre que me salía vale entonces lo que lo que
os comentaba veis al final el canal lógicamente tiene poquito de importar esto es retorno vamos
a poner el vamos a poner el fitness en esta es ahora porque sale aquí esto ahora no no que se
vea a veces a aprovechar se me abre debajo de todas las que tengo del youtube webinar entonces
no las puedo mover justo en fitness aquí y justo en fitness aquí que no es la misma de acuerdo
una es sortino y la otra es pero como veis es bastante bastante similar aquí sí que se aprecia
muy bien no que el canal pues bueno vale bien si poco mejor aquí poco mejor aquí los extremos pero
en general bastante bien vale para esto viene muy bien la marca de agua que tenés la barra aquí
la vas moviendo porque porque así como que te quita lo que no quieres ver es acordaros cuando
hice la práctica en excel que en el excel lo hacíamos así al final el excel cuando hacemos el
excel y no hacemos el mapa que también los lo enseñe a enseñar pero yo os dije que nosotros
normalmente en excel no lo hacemos nos quedamos con la con la tabla dinámica en colores porque
al final es esto es hacer esto visto desde arriba y con los colores cambiando el color
dependiendo el relieve ya ves un poco pero bueno es igual al final el objetivo es simplemente
ver la estabilidad de los parámetros de acuerdo ver la estabilidad de los parámetros no es otro
vale bueno se ven muy estables se ven muy muy estables sobre todo repito el canal en lo que
decía pero sí que es verdad aunque es verdad que aquí en la zona de 20 parece haber ahí una cierta
quiere estabilizar pero parece como quiere ese más más arriba no parece que se más allá por
tema de muestra también de velocidad de optimización pues no no queríamos llevarla mucho más arriba pero
tampoco estaría mal aquí ahora tampoco estaría mal pues analizar decir pues mira le voy a cortar
aquí en 0 18 y lo vamos a llevar bastante más arriba con un límite de trades mínimo pero para
ver si sigue sigue con la tendencia arriba porque porque si sigue indefinidamente queriendo subir
eso es un claro signo de que el esto no es eficiente recuerdo que esto es eficiente y
que no lo quiere y me puede decir hombre pero eso ya me lo has dicho que suele pasar ya pero no
olvidar que ese sistema no tiene otro mecanismo de salida yo por ejemplo esto en apolo por ejemplo
el sistema que operamos también ocurre que al final quiere un esto muy alto pero tiene otro
mecanismo de salidos apolo puede salir por otros métodos no sólo por esto pero esto es como un
hard stop y que un hard stop que salta pocas veces pero cuando salta te hace bastante daño no aquí
no es el caso que es su único mecanismo de salida le podríamos haber dejado que existe esa
posibilidad recordar salir por la media y tampoco estaría mal porque también es tendencial en ese
caso y en ese caso al final casi nunca habrá salido por esto sólo en algún día de volatilidad
salvaje que un día que era mucho y tanto pero casi nunca te hubieras salido por por esto que
siempre te hubieras salido por la media del canal y entonces el canal se hubiera vuelto más director
vale lo dejo también como como ejercicio para que probáis vosotros por cierto no lo no lo abierto
pero lo enseño aquí en el pdf aquellos que ya lo habéis visto lo tenéis ahí está explicada la
estrategia y al final está el código digiremos directamente este está ya limpia sólo con lo que
usamos no está la media pero podéis ponerla de acuerdo porque quería daros esta la que estamos
viendo sólo pura y dura vale si alguien quiere que le pase la cola media pues es bastante sencillo
no tiene mucha historia pero si alguien lo quiere se lo pasamos a ver vale pero recordar
que teníamos una versión con más salidas esto trailing ahí esto tp y también la salida por
el número de barras y por media por número de barras y buscamos un tendencial no me convence
como ya os comenté pero en media si tendría sentido si tendría sentido y así el canal se
volvería bastante más director bueno lo dejo como digo para que lo probéis vosotros de hacer
bien entonces aquí el mapa se ve bastante bien la verdad el mapa el mapa en general de los dos
tanto por upi como por se ve bastante bien se ve que el canal no es director y se ve que en esta
zona de 0 20 0 22 0 24 hay bastante estabilidad de acuerdo quizá aquí en 0 20 no es donde quizá
se ve mejor aunque aquí sí sí parece que también ya podemos aún forzarlo más ahí y veis como si
que se quiere cerrar ahí veis entre una planicia y 0 20 es decir esta zona un poco del pico pero
bueno todo el todo el 0 20 fijaros que es muy muy muy estable pero bueno cualquier caso ya os
digo toda esta zona está bien aquí creo que está fijado en uno ahora se ha fijado en uno
vamos a probar por ejemplo en el 0 y el troncero lo que os decía de cuidado con las auto escalas
porque al final los gráficos alto escala y por eso os decía que había quitado un poco de aquí
también vale había quitado de lo había dejado bajar el 0 10 para que no se me cayera tanto porque
si no al final como el gráfico se auto escala el valor mínimo que coges el mínimo que le da
entonces se la hace más o menos abrupta entonces por eso hay veces que interesa también cortarlas
porque meter mucho más hace que el valor inferior sea muy bajo o el valor superior sea muy alto y
como los gráficos auto escalan pues perdemos un poco de vista la dato de hecho aquí podría por
ejemplo aquí podría hacer esto pero subió bastante considerable si no esto es meterlas las distintas
variables todos los inputs ves así metidos chulo pero pero no es fácil de leer no quiero si se
va a interpretar bien así es la verdad lo dejamos así lo dejamos así entonces lo que lo que os
decía de la de la auto escala aquí lo que pasa que ahora sabéis qué pasa que con él con él
al tenerlo así se me está mira voy a quedarme sólo con el de sortino y así creo que lo podremos
ver mejor exactamente pisa que la escala el cost of fitness value es ahí veis el valor de abajo y
arriba vale a lo mejor lo tenemos fijaros ahora en 0 en 0 12 vale bueno se ve 0 12 es un poco más
0 14 por ahí vale cuando cambie aquí por ejemplo y ponga 0 5 es otro es otro y esto a veces es lo
que nos puede llevar a ver aquí tampoco hay mucha una gran variación pero puede haberla como
se auto escala yo sigo viendo el dibujo que está muy bien todo muy planito pero está planito más
arriba o más abajo entonces es el mismo problema que os digo siempre con los gráficos de acciones
o de futuros de que pues se auto escalan y a veces que eso engaña mucho a la percepción de los
movimientos parece que no se ha movido parece que se ha movido mucho realmente no se ha movido nada
porque tu ves hay un gráfico que tendencia que pasada se ha movido un 0 20 no es nada como el
gráfico se auto escala a la pantalla aquí pasa un poco lo mismo y como no te deja limitar este
valor sí que te deja elegir la variable y demás pero no te deja elegir el valor no y pues te puede
pasar te puede pasar eso vale para eso también tenemos luego como como habéis visto los datos en
excel para poder aquí verlos trabajarlos y aquí podemos ver todos sus valores mucho mejor todo
es complementario no sólo una cosa a otra vale no es una cosa u otra nos dicen cosas distintas
aquí vemos un poco como decía estabilidad y en general fijaros que hasta en todos ellos vemos
estabilidad siempre habrán unos más que en otros pero todos ellos vemos así lo que sí que viene
muy bien para esto pero esto lo quería decir se me olvidaba vale la marca de agua sí que no se
mueve vale es decir si yo por ejemplo pongo la marca de agua y veis que está ahora en 0 1 se
ve bien aquí vale no se mueve la marca de agua ahora yo voy a cambiar y la marca de agua va a estar
en 0 1 y eso viene muy bien para para evitar eso que os decía vale y era muy bien para eso 0 1
si se puede subir pero yo estaba que aseguró que te la dejaba fijar no te la dejan 0 1
pues la verdad es menos útil de lo que pensaba en ese caso sí porque ves yo la dejo aquí quita
0 1 y ahora te cambio de input y no la dejan 0 1 es lo totalmente lógico yo diría que son
pero bueno pero todos los programas de este tipo de dimensión al final de la marca de agua te la
dejan quieta porque es la gracia es lo que te sirve un poco de de marca de agua o sea de nivel
de control no te sirve de nivel de control de ver todo el rato dice bueno venga yo lo voy a dejar
de esto fijado aquí y vas viendo las distintas combinaciones de cómo te quedan a cada a cada
es un poco la gracia mi opinión eso no tengo que ir moviendo yo para eso no necesito la marca
si la tengo que ir moviendo yo no me hace falta marca de agua ya lo sé yo que de verdad todos
los problemas tienen algo es los problemas tienen algo también puede ser que sea un tema de precisión
porque ves como el 0 10 es muy claro como en realidad tengo tres decimales ahí puede ser
que sea eso es un efecto óptico que no se esté pasando nada que cojones bueno en definitiva en el
excel lo hemos visto bastante claro la zona que parecía más estable de más es en la zona de uno
aunque eso que os digo en todos va bastante bien bastante en todos los niveles de filtro va va
bastante bien no es un filtro muy muy muy potente pero sí que tiene tiene para hacer cierto nivel
de mejora yo la verdad cuando un filtro ya os lo comenté sólo aporta una cierta nivel de mejora
no soy muy partidario de meterlos vale pero bueno esto podemos hacer un análisis añadido es decir
que que cambia por ejemplo yo tengo aquí 5024 este 5024 por el filtro a cero donde está la vez
donde está entonces de entrada puedo quitar los otros filtros para que no me molesten
vale y vamos a buscar el 5 por ejemplo 024 que es número 1 ahí está 523 521 520 está bastante
bajo bueno he pasado el 524 no vamos a hacer una cosa vamos a bloquearlo y esa voy a dejar el 5
el 6 5 y 6 23 24 voy a dejar sólo los que los que me están saliendo y arriba es a los extremos
y aquí voy a dejar sólo 24 23 aquí bueno no lo veía realmente está muy muy abajo pero a mí me
interesa ver los trades bueno sí que son casi 203 de diferencia casi 203 de diferencia si sí
sí que tiene bastante bueno tiene un cierto impacto al final son dos trades por acción
aproximadamente de media dos trades por acción dos test por acción aproximadamente de media
entonces sé que tiene cierta implicación y sí que parece aportar bastante mejor a la verdad bien
entonces para acabar ya esta parte y hacer un pequeño escanso de 5 minutos 3 4 el 2 el 2 este
efecto como has visto antes en el canal fijaros que en este sólo hemos analizado el canal y hemos
bloqueado el filtro el filtro en cero porque esto sí que si estamos analizando el filtro lo metemos
al final y hemos dejado el trailing en 20 20 era un valor que no está mal y que vemos sólo el
canal de acuerdo estas digamos como podríamos haber empezado a analizar el sistema si no
supiéramos por dónde pillarlo voy a ver qué tal va el canal y vemos que en sample ya vemos
un poco eso vemos que fijaros tienes 13 9 24 8 no se ve una clara línea no se ve bastante
dispersión y en un sample igual aquí sí que se ve un poco lo mismo aunque sí que es verdad que el
que está arriba es 8 9 10 aquí el 8 está el sexto también decir también está muy bien colocado y
el 9 está segundo es decir realmente aquí sí que en in sample y out sample sólo el canal fijando
en 0 20 el traen en los datos que vemos en in sample y en out sample son muy muy parecidos son
realmente muy parecidos el demás retorno fijaros me dan 11 aquí el demás retorno me da 9 el que
da un pie sortino me da 23 aquí en cambio da 8 así que no no no concuerda pero en general
datos bastante bastante parecidos a la que miramos esta mezcla de equilibrio entre las cuatro
variables de acuerdo en el profit up y sortino ajustados recovery vale tenemos bastante bastante
lo mismo esto es bueno esto es bueno y al final vemos en all data pues es que hay valores altos
y valores bajos que esto es lo que hemos visto al final también valores bajos y valores altos bien
cuál elegir si vemos que es lo mismo bueno pero no es fácil no es fácil es verdad que no cuando
cuando un sistema esto también nos pasa bastante a veces en apolo cuando un sistema es bastante
robusto que va muy bien en distintas zonas pues no es fácil no es fácil elegir porque hay que
elegir alguno y no y no es sencillo vale en todo caso sí que lo haríamos ya en definitiva
usando los datos completos de acuerdo de la de la opti 1 pero esto como ya os comenté nosotros
cuando vamos a hacer la elección final no lo hacemos desde esta pero creo filtrado esto
no lo hacemos desde esta directamente desde aquí ya los quedamos de acuerdo vamos a ver
algo más de acuerdo vamos a ver el performance report y vemos algún dato más vemos la curva
esto es lo que nos da ya un poco el el filtrado final vale en este caso sí que
lo que ya tenía hecho limpiaría el filtro de acuerdo diría bueno me voy a quedar con cero
con uno acuerdos los he usado instrumentalmente pero no me no me interesan de acuerdo los los
quito voy a quedarme solo con cero y con uno es solo activo o no lo activo y si lo activo
activa 0 1 aunque me ha salido mejor 1 y medio 0 5 me da igual no me no me convence regularlo
darle tanto nivel de detalle y lo dejo en 0 1 sólo aquí ya hay algunos que los he eliminado
pero sí que mirando aquí sí que en sample sample vemos esa pequeña aparente contradicción
en que en sample nos salen canales muy altos y en un sample nos salen más bien canales bajos
y en el data nos sale los dos pero sí que en el trailing vemos esa
tendencia a la zona a la zona alta de 0 22 0 24 aquí sí que también te puede ayudar el mapa
que todos estos los llevaríamos y en este caso en un sistema multi activo donde lo acabaríamos
de afinar es el maestro nosotros esto lo pasaríamos ya el maestro y guardaríamos estos seds que lo
vamos a hacer ahora mientras hacemos el descanso vale para ya acabar de tomar la decisión mira
os voy a poner casi el descanso y mientras lo monto yo y así aprovechamos un poco más el tiempo
así que espérate coloco el relojito que siempre queda más chulo para ver si hoy quiero dejar
cerrado este sistema para pasar a pasar a otro 5 minutos de descanso y volvemos en nada
bien ya estoy por aquí vamos a ver esto bien vamos a ver aquí ahora a pasar vamos a pasar
a algunos sets por maestro he montado el visor que estuviera por favor bien montado y ha hecho
uno de prueba y simplemente pues vamos a haber hecho el 1 5 hacer el 1 6 y 4 6 y 0 24 al final
aquí no no sólo pensar que no sólo necesariamente que sí que es verdad que hay un punto objetivo
podemos hacer los amarillos los datos objetivos también nos lo hemos mostrado antes pero sí que
solemos también mirar la distribución en todas las todos los inputs por separados aquí miramos
la suma que es un poco el equilibrio de todos pero vez de ordeno por en el profit y vemos que se
quedan ahí bastantes amarillos en la parte la parte alta está diciendo mucho veo que no p pasa
un poco lo mismo vemos también que el sortino pasa pero menos los mejores de sortino no están ahí los
mejores de sortino no están ahí sí que el mejor de recovery aunque una posición bastante baja y
aquí quedan de hecho queda un poco más bajo pero queda la que los hemos mezclado todos
quedan bastante bajo para que da bastante bajo o sea que ya empieza a hacerlo un tanto sospechoso
pero no necesariamente lo descarta que esto es lo que ya os comenté es importante ver cómo se distribuye
todos los históricos y es verdad que aunque tratamos de distribuirlo en proporción tiene
un poquito más de peso no tendencial la parte más reciente la parte más reciente tiene un poquito
más de peso no tendencial porque tiene la parte del covid luego un tramo de tendencia bueno otro
más bilateral ahora y en cambio el el in sample sí que es verdad que tiene el 2010 en 2009 que
es muy muy duro pero luego tiene una serie alcista espectacular que le mete muchos años
favorables así que está ligeramente sesgada el in sample pero bueno lo dimos lo dimos por bueno
entonces aquí por ejemplo por qué porque el mejor sortino pues seguramente no está no está
0 y 1 normalmente también somos bastante partidarios de incluir este acuerdo de incluir
los mejores las variables en los sets es decir si si ya me aparecen el mejor mejor ya me sale es
el uno el mejor profile me sale el mejor upi también me sale el mejor recovery también me sale pero el
mejor sortino no me salía acuerdo así que lo meto de acuerdo lo meto lo meto y es un 24 22
de manera podemos decir artificial no sé por qué se me ha quedado marcado este sé porque éste no
se está quedando ahora es este acuerdo y ahora ya vuelvo a ordenar por suma vale entonces sé
que no era nada bien entonces ahora persigo montando estos últimos y los acabaremos comparando
para terminar de hacer una decisión sobre este sistema voy a meter este porque este me gusta
bastante no los voy a meter todos porque lo que importa es la idea y además yo ya sé lo que
vamos a hacer no quiero adelantarme 24 022 24 022 y canal 24 022 hemos metido este maestro
ya os digo que es un programa que a mí me gusta mucho a nivel de informes pero el de procesamiento
es infernal para que se va a que estén por favor traer los segundos unos como 5 10 segundos
este solo el backtest de un set ahora pues bueno voy a cambiarlo al revés lo voy a poner arriba
para que veáis lo que lo que tarda y eso que los datos ya los tiene bajados pero lo voy a hacer
al revés y no los voy a hacer todos voy a hacer solo algunos algunos de ellos que he hecho este
a ver a ver si los he hecho por fecha yo este 15 024 16 vamos a hacer unos 6 22 16 022 a los
años que ves lo que lo que tarda pasa que maestro nos da una información más que por
es mejor a nivel de para que lo veáis también porque me interesa pues que vayáis viendo cosas
esto también lo veríamos bien msa pero no me sabremos otro tipo más de quizá de futuros
porque para llevar los 100 históricos a allí nos va a llevar a ser un trabajo tremendo ya ha
acabado este mira voy a hacer otro para que tenga comparativa el el otro el 23 también
aquí es el mejor sortino esa zona 123 23 pero 24 que también está entre los amarillos bueno
general haríamos todos estos y ya digo los que destacan en algún ratio los que destacan
en amarillos todos estos serían los candidatos a llevarlos a ver su performance report completo
y esto cuando lo hacemos por sistema lo hacemos así pero lo sacamos de desde normalmente tres
y sacamos el performance report a excel y ya lo comenté en la teoría de manera independiente
a ver tú y yo pues analizamos los los performance reports para tomar una decisión de todas maneras
este sistema ya ahora ya sí que ya lo voy a adelantar yo creo que alguno ya se lo pensaba
yo no lo llevaría a operar no es un sistema que operaría su versión actual de acuerdo es decir
ya os comenté que vería acabaríamos procesos que llevarían a sistemas operar y que acabarían
los procesos que llevarían a sistemas a no operar y lógicamente explicaremos por qué porque si no al
final ver todo que sale perfecto por las majestuosas y demás es algo relativamente fácil pero no creo
que sea el objetivo del curso y de hecho no creo que se aporte nada entonces al final lo que aporta
es ver un poco cosas que mejor cosas que van ver las herramientas ver los procedimientos varias
veces y repetirnos y a base de verlos verlos entender la filosofía habrán en algunos que
serán procedimientos con un software con otro de distintas maneras pero pero no lo llevaría no es
que esté mal no es que o sea final como os comenté creo que lo vimos en la primera clase esto es
al final con que lo con que lo comparas y ahora mismo hecho aquí de 20 años no vale en el vallan
hall ya vimos con el nasdaq era imbatible decir imbatible el retorno era una locura mucho más
que esto porque porque al final te quedas comprado en un nivel muy son muchos años ya has hecho un
interés compuesto alucinante que aquí no conseguimos no conseguimos realmente ganemos
no ganamos menos no ganamos muchísimo menos muchísimo menos que ahora lo hacemos mejorando
el drag down si mejoramos el drag down mejoramos mucho pero no lo suficiente no lo suficiente
podríamos hacer más cosas es decir realmente el sistema querido simplificar la idea tendencial
para que vierais el clásico sistema tendencial entrada estructura y con un trailing vale se
podrían hacer más cosas y probablemente iría mejor con un con un y con un stop normal sin ser
trailing de acuerdo y era te irá yo lo que puede ser probarlo vosotros para dejar este trabajo en
todos los sistemas os iré dejando cositas y días para probar probar que tenga un hard stop lo que
decía antes y que salga con la media del doncha con la parte media del doncha o incluso otra versión
muy hard es ir a la banda contraria del doncha contraria el doncha sería bastante bastante
hardcore con hard stop con stop de seguridad pero pero así yo personalmente no lo operaría ya
digo que sí que mejora el riesgo al vallampol pero no mejora lo suficiente para para compensar
la enorme pérdida de retorno que supone pero bueno final esto es como todo la curva de más
fijaros qué curva tenemos que aquí uno de los uno de los problemas de este buen programa es aunque
sí que se puede hacer en teoría logarítmico pero ya veréis ya veréis el logarítmico que sacamos
cuesta una vida y es horroroso es horroroso no tengo que hacer empezar en 100.000 los 3 lo acabo
en 5.500 2 3 este que de cien estamos os lo he dicho bueno que lo voy a bajar un poco más aquí
el pasado es infumable esto es el programa no puedo hacer más hay que ir eligiendo los
sexes ya no pero bueno pero al menos a menos la vez el logarítmico que queda mejor mejor porque
al final en lineales se ve el drama mucho peor de lo que es pero bueno que sigue siendo importante
estamos hablando un sema que anualiza 21 22 por 21 por ciento compuesto con una exposición
que no llega a nunca ser del doble no está mal no es tampoco no está muy mal llega un
momento es ponerse a dos veces a palanca dos veces y tiene una de un 40% no perdón no 40
46 46 es justo es pobre acuerdo es pobre si hubiéramos hecho 20 y 20 por ejemplo sería
mejor bien ahí estaríamos más razonable pero 20 por ciento anualizado con 45 de no
darles es demasiado para mí no sería suficiente no sería suficiente pero
bueno la idea y adiós la idea inicial la idea inicial de entrada de don chan es totalmente
válida donde por ejemplo este sistema incluso así iría probablemente mejores en materias primas
seguramente oro petróleo puede ser que fuera soja cosas así pues así podría ser que fuera
que fuera bien pero de otras maneras insisto que aún así creo que le plantearía algún cambio
le plantearía un cambio para mejorar bien de los que hemos hecho para que veáis en el caso que
quisiéramos quedarnos con uno como ejemplo hemos empezado por este hoy vale y aquí que miramos
bueno aquí miramos poco curvas drawdown ratos de retorno riesgo cual nos dan al final aquí de los
que no hemos visto aquí sólo tenemos sharp en este caso diario y rr 087 y aquí tenemos el
r anual y el char sigue siendo diario no se ha anualizado pero vamos a publicar nosotros 0 0
75 por raíz de lo fácil 370 da 109
109 yéndolo ya por por por 360 da 109 es realmente justo fijaros aquí un 80 por ejemplo
aquí tenemos un 80 igual 2 19 1 92 este 1 24 02 por sorpresa era el sortino ya lo sospechaba que
ya por ahí la cosa es el que sale con mejor es verdad y también mejor usar en este caso
pero 0603 a mí me gusta mucho el sortino yo os lo dije
y veis que por raíz de 360 pues mejoran un poquito pero 1 14
sería 1 1 14 sharp anualizado 2 19 de triple r 23 71 de compuesto y aquí con un drawdown de
44 76 bajado un par de puntos pero bueno sigue siendo un drawdown demasiado demasiado alto
y aún así aquí otro otro línea de mejora la línea de mejora importante y ligo otra vez
con las consultas que me había hecho antes aureli sería un poco y decir esto al final
simplemente le hemos hecho como decía para validar la estrategia yo en el caso como lo
planteara operar que haríamos otro tipo otro tipo de análisis y miraríamos reduciríamos
reduciríamos la cesta reduciríamos la cesta sales más lecciones por ejemplo lo que hemos
hablado antes un criterio por supuesto de rendimiento sería sería válido otro no
menor de histórico es decir donde podamos mirar más que ha hecho esa acción porque aquí no todas
las acciones tienen el mismo histórico de acuerdo este es un problema aquí no tenemos tampoco sesgo
de supervivencia aquí abajo nos ha hecho la tv student ya va a hacer el programa automática
en la mayoría aunque va a haber salido alguno que no la mayoría ves que te da que sí que si
tienes alguno que no seguramente pere dinero y saber algunos que tienen perdido dinero otros
que ven entonces yo aquí puedo analizar y puedo ver todas las acciones que me gusta el maestro
que tengo cien repito puedo ver un poco pues dónde están aquellas las puedo apuntar y
puedo tratar de hacerme alguna alguna cesta y ver en esas un poco como ha ido pero pero bastante
se recordarán acciones lo que os dije aquí el riesgo de gap es enorme el riesgo de gap es
enorme que hace el 10% entonces hay que ir a una exposición muy muy baja de acuerdo porque
tú has expuesto un 2 y te meten un 10 te has metido un 20 y estás expuesto un 2 es poco entonces
este es el problema por eso tenemos también tanto de lo que te han cazado muchas en algunos momentos
han cazado muchas y te las tragas y además cuando hay caídas de mercado globales te las tragas
todas claro y te meten un gap y te cosiste el problema de este tipo de estrategias en acciones
que cuesta mucho de controlar riesgo con estrategia o sea con sobre optimización es fácil pero en la
realidad con estrategias como esta que no están sobre optimizadas porque están miradas en cien
acciones no es fácil pero así fíjate aureli tienes aquí está que digamos ratio de profit factor por
ponerlo fácil no que si no nos vamos a hacer un poco trampas viendo un poco el valor de cada uno
profit factor aquí mira esto tenemos 259 pero cuando estrés tiene y estrés no van a tener mucho
las que más van a tener van a tener 20 algo más bueno pues tienes aquí unas cuantas que pueden
estar ahí en el ratio de profit factor de 2 que a lo mejor pues merecen una mayor 11 estos
demasiado seguramente como si no muchos a bueno es envidia claro miras un cohete claro lógicamente
las más volátiles se ayudarán más que hemos metido de todo y eso mejoraría mucho la cartera y
esto ya digo son deberes que los dejo a vosotros con esta simple estrategia y ahora probarlo en
distintas acciones no me puedo usarlo maestro pasa nada tú coge el programa que tengas el mismo
código lo vas cargando aquí para una acción a la otra todos los programas tienen este mecanismo
de la tabla al lado y lo vas probando a ver o sea he visto ahí envidia me han dicho que la ver en
aquí las tengo ordenadas por market cap quiere decir que envidia está por aquí
qué pasa que envidiamos como es un misil vamos a poner este mismo set y lógicamente si tú
encuentras una cesta de 20 acciones 20 acciones que está por defecto con 20 con 20 024 creo
que el que teníamos aquí era 24 022 y 4 022 y con el filtro activado en uno aquí tenemos
que lógicamente envidia es un misil envidia ha sido un misil dices hombre en esa estrategia va
bien pero bueno no digo que no siga yendo igual de bien de verdad puede ser la estrategia repito
esta validad en todas y por lo tanto se ha analizado en todas o sea puede ser que siga
yendo bien perfecto pero hay que tener en cuenta que una estrategia en acciones ligo un poco con lo
que pregunta y aureli de cómo recomiendo el rebajar el drama sobre todo sobre todo con
diversificación porque al final o sea el problema de los sistemas tendenciales puros es este es
decir si tú tienes un tendencial puro insisto insisto aureli que es demasiado más de 40 pero
pero es igual en pongo lo bajar a los 10 puntos porque tal vez tampoco te pido bajarlo al 20 vale
una tendencia al pura sabrá tendencia al pura que es capaz de ganar esto esta locura
sobre hablar fuertes porque para ganar esto también te has tragado alguna acción que no
entonces al final ese es el problema pues ahí lo hemos validado en todas y conseguimos que
tengamos algo muy fuerte y tú ahora podrías podrías aplicarlo a lo mejor a 10 acciones que
ya te he dicho que no cogería las 10 como esta perdón 20 20 al menos no cogería las 20 como
estas pero a lo mejor 10 sí que cogería donde ha ido muy bien y tenga bastante histórico cuidado
pero lo que hemos cogería algunas que a lo mejor pues no tanto por lo que fuera a lo mejor porque
está lateral ese activo pero bueno no tiene por qué estarlo siempre mejor ahora envidia de pronto
se acaba esto y no sube nunca más es que al final el problema el problema es que no conocemos el
futuro envidia ahora va muy bien ya ya ya no sé qué va a hacer pero irá siempre así no sé a lo
mejor de pronto no sé tesla de pronto su software de coches que dicen que es el mejor de auto se
ponen todos de moda decide que todas mangas que es que 4 es una mierda se lo voy a comprar a
tesla y tesla automáticamente empieza a vender software a todas las marcas de coches
esto me lo he inventado totalmente pero me entendéis entonces este es el módulo 5 del curso
latin de trading pero si el mercado no lo es simplemente no lo es bueno las acciones de este
tipo de nuevas ideas que quiero decir que ya no y veo que el contrato es de los meses que
ya nada es espectacular y los años sin hacer nada ahora se lo hubiera escogido en el 19 a 15
pues claro está a 200 sin hacer nada lleva y es a 200 habías podido comprar a 5 no hace tantos
años entiendes decir al final bueno es este tipo de cosas caro ese tipo de cosas las coges con
este tipo de acciones pero vamos a estar en el lado corto la has cogido tesla no al lado corto
con el doncha pero pero este es el tema entonces aquí la diversificación sobre la mejor manera es
con una cartera con porfolio a nivel de control de sistema es lo que te digo esto lo expliqué
y alguien creo que en el foro en él en él en el chat ya hubiera en el disc or lo comentó no sé si
fue en el disc or lo de que en él el profit target de mejorar a las mejoras a las salidas no que era
contraintuitivo algo así bueno no recuerda bueno las salidas sal el tp es una cosa que
mejora más el riesgo de lo que parece mejora mucho el módulo 6 el cura en un tenencial no
hay tp entonces sólo lo puede ser donde veremos y tú vas a tener que apurar a todo tipo de órdenes
también cosas que muchos términos en inglés es importante que nos quedemos con estos términos
y he pensado en hacer porque no vamos a decir es algo que es muy importante
porque además se aprende que se aprende más al error del texto que del acierto
y en el curso pues yo también lo planteado así de acuerdo de cómo se aprende más del error
pues aquí los señal cosas que no son perfectas de acuerdo porque es la parte uno de aprender
es más de ellas latín de trading que de que ellos enseñen que bien va esto que va bien
baquero largo contra corto y las probabilidades la curva del disco a error de programación vale
bueno a ver a decir que no es replicable no es verdad eso básico para comenzar en tres
compran la identidad venden fortaleza tomando en cuenta la tendencia esto creo que es uno de
los mejores que el establo el micro lo cuentas y uno de los mejores conceptos para entender
este concepto fundamental necesitamos el error de programación en tres es muy complicado que ya
lo hemos venido pero acabamos entonces en tendencias alcistas tal y como vimos conviene
ir largo es decir como el micro la acción y en tendencias bajistas conviene ir corto
o vender la acción la tendencia más fuerte es la que tenga mayor es decir una temporalidad de
un minuto y el error viene de los siguientes y usted buscando un sistema en el que digamos me
haga me haga un break even y justo en los pares del yen me falla el porcentaje de recorrido que
tiene que hacer para que entre en break even y me entra en break even prácticamente al inmediato
y cuál es mi sorpresa cuando paso por los pares del yen veo esta maravilla de curva que no solo
sucede en esta en muchos otros pares entonces ahora lo estoy intentando validar en mt4 porque
claro aquí que haga muy poquito recorrido y ponga break even nos esto hace que pues nunca haya
porque sólo quedan las buenas lo que pasa es que la entrada del sistema no es casi nunca coincide
con la entrada teórica que te plantas en el trade station ya sea en el open next buy next
bar o bien on close entonces esto cuando lo intentas replicar en la vida real lo estoy
intentando hacer en mt4 no consigues no consigues esto si tenéis la solución de un error de back
test más bien no sería error de bueno no porque realmente si tú miras la curva o sea mira esas
operaciones que hace trade station y son correctas pero luego en la vida real esas operaciones no se
pueden ejecutar o sea nunca se ejecutan ese precio porque en la apertura en forex al día es en daily
además la apertura del día siguiente suele haber unos deslizamientos unas rupturas que dan miedo
claro pero eso es por el tema de spread claro o sea porque en forex tienes bt ask y no tienes el
last entonces ahí en trade station no estás back testando contra el last no lo sabes back
testando contra el bt el ask exacto en la vida real pero no puedes o sea yo no sé cómo
se pueda o no es un error de back test o sea cuando te quiero decir un error de programación es que
estás haciendo algo que no es que no puedes hacer es decir estás leyendo a futuro el error de back
test es que no estás consiguiendo si no estás consiguiendo replicar la realidad que es justo lo
que dices tú no estás consiguiendo replicar la realidad de lo que pasa en el back test así es
vale vale si queda queda entendido queda entendido bueno ahora profundizo un poco más te cierro el
micro gracias aureli muchas gracias has debutado es el primero que hable si bueno lo que comenta
en el forex claro entre este son que por cierto aurelín multicharts permite hacer eso vale te
lo digo porque eso tres station no lo permite bueno no lo permite no lo permite en el sentido
de dos datas y puedes penalizar con slip page el hecho que también podrías hacerlo así pero es
bastante más real te lo voy a mostrar a que lo ha cerrado multichart lo abro un momento te lo voy
a mostrar porque multichart si lo permite multichart si lo permite y creo que te puede venir bien esta
característica a ver si me acuerdo rápido donde estaba pero creo que te lo podré enseñar o sea
tres station a nivel de back test tú vienes aquí al sistema recuerda mal properties exactamente si
un soporte aquí en el modo de back test se ve bien este dice back testing mode classic que es back
testear lo en la serie de datos donde está metido o extendido que es back test se abre en el beat y
el asiento tú le dices que para as usa esta serie de datos y para beat usa otra que lógicamente
también tienes que tener metida en el gráfico entonces tú le puedes meter la serie del beat la
serie de las que puede ser importada puede ser de otro vendor y back testearlo así back testearlo
con as bit y eso será bastante más real eso será bastante más real porque eso te pasa porque la
ventaja es estrecha cuando la ventaja es estrecha claro importa importa mucho el bricky ven de todas
maneras tiene tendencia a tener problemas de este de este tipo porque el bricky ven al uso
que se activa a partir de una cierta cantidad muchas veces nos pasa eso que nos ejecuta muy
rápido y ahí por un lado tienes que ir a lo que hablábamos antes del lift de acuerdo tener muy
claro cómo abre y tener muy claro el slipage a lo mejor tienes que penalizar con muchos slipage si
no es reproducible pero de todas maneras el camino más cercano a probarlo va a ser probar
esto que te he dicho multicharts si poniendo que tengas multicharts que ahora no lo sé claro si
tienes multicharts si tienes multicharts te recomiendo probar esto a probar no no tienes
multicharts vale entre station sí que tienes no puedes directamente hacerlo pero podrías hacerlo
directamente podríamos o sea podrías montarte tú pero no con datos del sino con datos porque
ahora no aunque sí que estaban no alberto los datos de antes estaban o que no sé si ahora están
está el vídeo las que entre este son de divisas desde estaba no era euros punto no punto era punto
ahí lo tiene ese señor sí que está entonces te puedes meter el ask y el beat en un dato
recuerda que sólo puedes operar en el data uno sólo puedes operar en el data uno pero puedes
consultar puedes preguntar al puedes preguntar a las veces yo tengo aquí arriba bueno vamos a pasar
lo de gario no es ahora arriba tengo el beat el as que abajo tengo el beat es que está 93 está
90 y yo siempre voy a tirar la orden al beat pero como puedo consultar perdón perdón en este
en este ejemplo que te estoy mostrando voy a tirar la orden al ask que sé que está arriba pero yo
puedo puedo consultar el data 2 acuerdo que es el beat en el data 1 tengo las que en el data 2
tengo el beat ahora mismo como puedo consultar uno u otro pues puedo puedo jugar un poco con
eso y ver más cerca de la realidad no sé si me estoy explicando que yo ejecuto arriba puedo
hacerlo con una regla que dependa del de abajo entonces penalizar en base a eso mejor no puedes
hacer un balance un poco mejor así recomiendo explorar esta esta opción porque al final el
problema aquí es este no que en el forex aunque las plataformas de futuros y lo pintan porque va
así donde está la matrix en realidad en realidad en el forex no hay aunque sí que hay no hay las
como tal entiende la idea que ellos que no estoy familiarizados aprovecho para introducir este
este concepto está el as que está el beat es que es este spread aquí está pintado ahora el euro
a que se es el as que en realidad pero si ahora pinto aquí el euro dólar que va a ser mejor es
el que es primario pues ves aquí yo tengo que está el último cruce a 97 pero ves aquí está el
as que está a 802 7802 y el beat lo tengo a 7992 entonces yo si compro a mercado lo que hago es
atacar el as y si vendo a mercado lo que hago es atacar el beat y entonces bueno como puedo
pintar los dos en un gráfico pues puedo tratar de mejorar el backtest con eso exploró un poco ese
camino si si comenta fran pregunta que si quiere hacerlo meta trader se puede considerar un spread
más elevado para que compensa el spread de slipage y si el problema el el problema real del spread
fran de este problema en el fondo no es tanto de reproducir el slipage porque eso es fácil sino
de ejecutar la realidad porque si yo yo el de arriba es el as y el de abajo es el beat vale es decir
el de arriba para que me entendáis pinta el rojo el de arriba pinta la columna roja
vamos a hacerlo así para para no hasta para mí porque me equivoco continuamente como yo no estoy
muy acostumbrado a operar pero si operamos los dps pero pero automáticamente sabes no no tengo
con sube de mirarlo continuamente esto vale entonces al final yo el de abajo me está pintando el en la
columna azul esta casilla de aquí vez esta casilla que está como más marcada se ve no sea si os
fijáis yo entiendo que porque esto tiene una resolución bastante buena donde está el lápiz de
verdad el lápiz este y yo nos vamos a hacer amigos nunca a ver lo pinto en amarillo y lo marco aquí
es esto que la cosa menos pesada pensada salen cosas interesantes no es ahí eso esa eso es el
el beat y ese es lo que se va moviendo y eso que no se mueve aquí porque porque
tres estes son bueno pero esa esa era la que pinta cada uno vale esa es la que pinta cada
uno de acuerdo eso es lo que cada uno va pintando entonces el problema es que yo si pongo el sistema
aquí el que sea yo pongo un sistema aquí el cuando compre cuando compre sí que va a reflejar
la realidad porque yo compro imagina que tiro a mercado contra las pero cuando venda va a seguir
vendiendo contra las y realmente vende contra el beat pero el sistema que va a correr en este
gráfico el sistema que va a correr en este gráfico algo que ejecute mucho ahora vale
yo compro venda aquí he comprado vale y me dice que he comprado a unos 7 8 1 9 y ese precio
probablemente ha sido real porque como es el rojo he comprado en este precio pero este me dice que
ha vendido a 1 7 7 5 6 y no es verdad ha vendido más abajo ha vendido 45 ticks por debajo no es
verdad ese precio entonces es un problema ya no tanto desde la deslizamiento que lo puedo simular
sino que habrá veces que sea el mínimo o el máximo y marque ejecutado cuando realmente no
ha ejecutado tienes la idea sea el problema es más de réplica eso a nosotros nos ha pasado mucho este
ya lo contado porque al subir los tipos de interés en los futuros ha subido mucho ese spread esa
diferencia entre entre el futuro y el cfd porque el cfd el tipo de interés lo tiene fuera o tienen
su app en cambio el futuro lo tiene implícito pero ahora es otro tema pero el problema ha sido el
mismo vale de que la compra va si yo ejecuto en este gráfico el sistema la compra se hace correcta
la venta no y en este es lo contrario la compra no se hace correcta la venta así entonces bueno
puedo jugar un poco con eso porque yo como puedo consultar el de abajo cuando calcula un precio
de venta estaba para aurel y lo calculo en el de abajo cuando calcula un precio de compro lo
calculo en el de arriba y con eso puedes tirar un poco y luego aparte también evidentemente con
solucionarlo pero el problema en el histórico tiempo real es simular que realmente ejecutó lo
que tocaba y ese problema en el vídeo las que hay es spread que a veces ejecutas por poco cuando
ejecutas por poco no puede ser verdad pero puede ser que no vale bueno tenía ya para acabar del
sistema este lo que lo que os comenté el tema de los cortos vale el tema de los cortos a nivel
global es muy complicado lógicamente si lo miras a nivel de algunas acciones lo vas a encontrar y
no es difícil no es difícil pero al uso tendencial no vale lo máximo que encontraríamos es
es a ver dónde estoy yo que no he perdido pues ves aquí por ejemplo antes la fíjate es la
entonces la creo que hasta va a ir directamente tendencia de todo parece lo parece pero no
porque claro tiene un momento está configurado pero aquí que iría más bien pues seguramente
entradas y ya digo atrás de rotura en un canal a lo mejor que no sea muy lejano no
tráiler es bastante arriesgado ir a salida puede por tiempo no sé tres cuatro barras
es lo que tenemos y luego recuerden que para comprar en debilidad y vender en fortaleza
entonces en este caso fíjense en este punto hay una debilidad por buscar a buscar explosiones
a lo que pasa es que te va a meter más grande también
pero es muy difícil recuerden que el 90% de los traidores es una entrada muy lenta
es una entrada muy lenta el don chan y cuando te pilla las buenas no lo vas a dejar correr
sabes pero la verdad es complicado te va a tragar muchas malas en ese tipo de entradas
es mejor ir a expansión de volatilidad cuando detectes alguna expansión de volatilidad entrar
y cierro una posición cuál es la mayor ganancia cuál es cuál es la probabilidad de éxito que
tiene más probabilidad de éxito en acciones de small caps ir en largo a ver la disponibilidad
de acción que va a repercutir en nuestra operativa al revés esto muy que son las comisiones que
pagamos aquí al revés la primera que vamos a analizar es cómo abro yo una posición estando
en largo yo abro una posición están comprando y como yo abro una posición estando en corto
vendiendo es decir ninguna posición abierta pero quiero abrir una posición en largo
y quiero una posición en corto pero tengo que hacer en mtsl es muy complicado comprar
corto de manera que cuando compro mil acciones mi posición va a ser pero bueno ya digo en algunas
acciones es muy difícil entrando con don chan porque es una entrada el principal problema de
esta entrada es que es muy retrasada y si la vamos a probar el extremo perdiendo el mínimo del día
anterior a un día para el loco esto ya es loco el press down sea el low es el high vamos allá
por todas y si va muy bien fantástico seguramente a una ahora que acercarlo más el tp no y que
he hecho me equivocado pero 40 no 004 muy complicado corto tengo que volver de manera que mi posición
va a ser ahora menos química y así de esta manera es como yo ya probaremos alguno tipo
apolo en acciones a ver qué tal a ver si nos sale que sé que por ahí pediendo apolo ya veremos
algo tipo apolo lo probaremos en acción es apolo en el lado corto en el nasdaq funciona aunque
por ejemplo este año la cosa mucho esta es la parte 2 de la terminología esto es porque
es muy importante a la hora de hacer trading porque acabamos de ver cuál es el lenguaje que
utilizan los traders y sobre todo vamos a ver y vamos a entender en las estrategias
estos son todos los términos que vamos a ver parecen muchísimos y parece muy abrumador esto
pero la verdad cuando vean lo sencillo que es y lo simple no les haría de preocupar esto es para
que seguimos de todas las cosas que vamos a ver en este módulo sobre dice que es decir lo primero
vamos a ver un concepto que es de watchlist cuando escuchen decir a coño don chan claro
claro no no don chan si nada es la hora es la hora me dijeron sobre don chan con stop y te ve y te
y te ve igual que eso es un buen truco para medir un edge vale pero es verdad que para los
tendenciales cuidado pero sí que es un buen es un buen es un buen truco rápido para ver casi
ninguna te pasaba del 50 claro y si calculado con atr una unidad por cinco días si el truco es
bueno pero es para evaluar la entrada de manera rápida pero es verdad que los tendenciales lo
que te digo tienen que correr entonces a veces a lo mejor te puedes probar a darle 2 a 1 me sabes
dejarle así y de eso bueno que ya lo veremos en una clase quiero hacer una clase que tengo que
porque la tengo más o menos las clases pensadas y planeadas pero no el orden pensé sobre la marcha
no como pide la clase pero como van las preguntas y demás pero sí que hay una que haremos búsqueda
de patrones y uno de ellos por supuesto es ese y hay otro que es con la rotura del máximo del
día anterior y cerrar al cierre por ejemplo y esto va bien para ver la tendencia de ese activo
sabes para ver si las roturas de un día marcan tendencia o no y también lo puedes hacer en
intradía para ver si en el intradía y tendencia puedes tener fails pero pero pero al final te
dices en intradía tiene tendencia yo si rompe el máximo de ayer entro largo y al cierre ciego con
eso mira si el activo de la día tiene tendencia nos salen todas pero muchas acciones de muchos
activos te sale veremos cositas de estas un día que haremos con un código lo haremos varias de
ellas y nos iremos pasando en distintos activos de acciones futuros de distinto tipo para para
veáis distintas maneras de encontrar entradas vale que ya dijimos que veríamos bastantes querido
empezar por el doncha porque sé que ha hablado mucho de él en el curso y además es bueno de
verdad lo que pasa que tiene sus puntos débiles de sus puntos débiles y que donde va mejor el
doncha de salir o sea es lo mismo que has visto en el lado largo que lo podéis explorar en
vez de trailing en rotura no lo hemos hecho tal pero cuando os lo he dicho esto mismo igual pero
yo lo dejo ahora bueno da igual porque está bloqueado para cortos pero voy a activar esto
que me da igual no me importa mucho voy a dejar original a cero vamos a pasar ahora en cuanto
rompa es algo así y aquí me salgo en 10 días habría que habría que ver habría que verle que
rango le en que rango le metes pero bueno habría que verlo habría que verlo pero lo mismo buscar
la explosión y salir de buscar la explosión y salir de esto y hasta 20 es demasiado podría
ser mejor para 10 pero bueno ya digo es poco sensible canal como hemos visto es poco sensible
con chan en general esto lo puedes probar las 10 acciones es decir en vez de ir al training o incluso
dejando el trailing incluso dejando el trailing hasta suponiendo pocos cambios de la versión
actual es decir no mira no no liar vale dejanse entre el link vale como lo tenías que era más
o menos vamos a hacerlo subiendo lo mismo que tenías no vamos a dejar 20 igual 0 20 va 0 20
con 20 vale pero a mí es al mismo tiempo lo que se ha dicho le pruebas a la mente le dejas la media
puesta ya verás que el trailing nos va a actuar casi nunca bueno le he dejado el time perdón le he
dejado el time se lo puede dejar pero ahora por probar lo que quiero bueno va a salir algunas
veces por tele algunas veces por media y así lo con más que la media se le va a pegar mucho se
le va a pegar mucho y esta es otra variante que es un poquito más más rápida y que en muchos
actores va a ir muy muy bien pero muy bien también es de dejar correr pero dejar correr menos luego
ya lo que os decía decir en vez de esto a días esta es la que en muchos roturas se usa eso
y ya está incluso mejor el tiempo es un poquito más más cerrado y os va a salir en muchos veces
en tiempo no va a salir esto va a salir en tiempo y se pueden hacer varias variantes que ya
no sean el propiamente tendencial y que va a ir en muchas alguna mejor no irá también pero
va a ir para el muy bien en muchas porque porque al final sale el mercado antes tienen distintas
maneras para salir eso sale por tiempo que sí que algunas veces pues saldrá mal pero pero mucho
saldrá bien incluso en vida que ya veréis aquí no va a ser tan aquí por ejemplo seguramente irá
típico pero también en las caídas veis pues como se salen 10 días pues al final se sale antes
a lo mejor que con él con el don chan pero claro las subidas tendidas se va saliendo se va metiendo
se va saliendo se va metiendo pero esta es una variante esto no te va a dar ratios tan tendenciales
pero también te va a dar ratios tendenciales este 46 te va a dar 30 y pico como antes no lo hemos
mirado antes en maestro pero esto debía dar esto debía dar 30 es 40 47 pues mira un da más de
lo que pensaba prácticamente da más de lo que pensaba pensaba que daría menos pensaba que daría
menos y el porcentaje de aciertos con este set up 44 46 46 47 dependiendo del set 44 47
pensaba que daría más de verdad se parece mucho bueno prácticamente el mismo bueno en vida
seguramente daba más en ese este es seguramente envidia era de las que más porcentaje daba de
acierto digo yo habíamos visto gráfico antes era espectacularmente tendencial claro una locura
envidia estará por aquí a nos ha ordenado esto por alfabético no porque es ordenado
no sé porque se ha ordenado bueno pues no sé da igual habrá de aquí con porcentaje de acierto
es muy alto y habrá con menos esto ya os digo aquí es aquí aquí lo veis 40 a 47 50 33 100
pero muy poco es decir al final habrá un poco de todo pero las que han tirado más como envidia
todo esto pues seguro que tiene un porcentaje altísimo lo que no sé ahora porque no la veo
es que hay 100 no es fácil encontrarla no no sé por qué no lo tiene ordenado como estaba aquí
esa microsoft es igual seguro seguro seguro que tiene un porcentaje de acierto bajo el cambio google
carlos 55 55 quiere decir que aquí google igual en esto va mejor en esta en estas etapas y más
más tendido para momentos que sí momentos que no muy justita aquí si aureli comenta perdón
para realizar los rangos de parámetros pregunta fran es es buen sistema usar que
el clínic si lo hacemos no sesgamos la zona paramétrica ahora mismo me pillas
cuando me acuerdo que era que el minuto lo he leído es aquel que bajan por el lado suelo
por el otro darte más explicación que la que te he dado ahora me voy a me voy a liar
no sé no sé no sé decirte nada nada más en concreto comenta aureli lo de las tortugas
pero miro me lo miro para el próximo día y te lo respondo calmo porque lo he leído pero no
me acuerdo mismo el detalle exacto concreto aureli pregunta las tortugas de las tortugas son
exactamente un don chan aureli es exactamente es exactamente lo que pasa que es un don chan
que lo hacía si no recuerdo mal eran semanal tengo un libro por ahí de hecho y sí que era
básicamente eso la clave una de las claves de las tortugas era la gestión monetaria que no
no se ha propagado eso no se ha propagado totalmente eso pero pero tenían una gestión monetaria muy
estricta y era era lo que iban promediando a favor era una manera de su de fallaron muchísimo
después de ciertos megabajos es decir se iban un poco a buscar las envidias entonces la cuando
pillaban una envidia la añadían añadían añadían se iban apalancándose en ella y claro los revientas
es que los revientas es verdad son acciones es así o sea tú pillas la que lo revienta y es
tremendo y se basaban un poco un poco en eso se basan un poco en eso vale pero esta franze
quieres ponla si quieres en el discord lo que me has puesto si no te importa más que nada porque
así te la me queda me queda archivada vale me queda archivada que vas a una preguntita más por
ahí para cerrar dejó el sistema este ya por cerrado ya os he dejado si si alguien quiere el
es que le puse como más cosas un poco para probando distintas que ya lo hicimos el primer día y ahora
mismo pues un poco pero realmente por eso se ha dado el pdf de solo la versión esta porque
es un poco la que hemos visto más a fondo y hemos trabajado un poco un poco más pero
franze para ti que el mismo es el algoritmo que usa
el poder en la esta de acciones aberto que no conecta mercado como se llama a mi
no es no no no no no no no no no era la que usa la que usa
es la que usa
de todas maneras hay bastante yo es como aprovecho porque el enjambre de partículas
también hay gente que al final yo no he leído nada ni visto nada súper concluyente que
que mejor el algoritmo genético de verdad es que es es que al final y no no creo honestamente
si hay algún paper por ahí que se me ha escapado pues pásame lo que lo leeré atentamente pero
pero no creo de verdad que incluso ya por mi sentido común de mi experiencia que realmente
haya un algoritmo que mejore mucho es la lógica que tiene algoritmo genético la misma que tiene
partículas y seguramente es al final bien son lógicas de búsqueda de de búsqueda de
zonas robustas que que al final todos siguen un poco lo mismo y a mí la de algoritmo genético
también me parece muy razonable muy lógica y fomenta totalmente eso bueno siempre hay algo
que sale que es mejor en teoría que no sé qué pero realmente es una gran mejor a eso pues a mí
no me lo ha parecido las veces que yo he leído sobre otros algoritmos de búsqueda que es de lo
que hablamos un poco se llamen perico que ya bueno y has visto toda la teoría ya ya me conoces el
tema de los nombres que son muy poco amigos porque como no tengo memoria no me acuerdo de las cosas
pues al final le el nombre a todo y y lo que importa son más las ideas entonces el el tema
el algoritmo de búsqueda no creo yo que esté ahí la gran cosa no creo la verdad que no pero
bueno ya digo al final evidentemente que se ha abierto que estar muy abierto siempre es muy
importante a cualquier cosa nueva tal pero no es lo que es muy antiguo pero prefiero que cualquier
cosa que sale ser atento a posibles mejoras no pero pero ya digo muchas al final acaban siendo
poco de lo mismo da una vuelta de otra manera mejor más rápido o lo que fuera pero es un poco
y no acaban de provocar unas grandes mejoras porque siempre hay gente pues más de pensura de una cosa
y de la otra y esto pasa mucho lo buscaré si tienes alguna fuente por ahí me la pasas y la
la miraré con calma y a ver qué da pero aunque estoy 100 por ciento seguro que leído sobre
tanto sobre el hambre como el rey pero pero vaya hace tiempo y no recuerdo que me quedara
la conclusión de que fuera algo mejor ni nada pues voy a ir cortando amigos si no hay más
preguntas hasta el lunes que viene recordar que los jueves hacemos directo recordar que los jueves
hacemos directo a quien se quiera pasar para poner alguna preguntita y también también puede
también puede de acuerdo la clase se procesa el vídeo y en un ratito la tenéis ya subida de
acuerdo nada más la semana que viene bueno vamos a poner el discord de que te crearemos la semana
que viene porque tengo que mirar las las notas y decidiré pero mi idea era empezar ahora hemos
hecho uno de la parte podemos decir acciones diarios semanal recordar no que hablamos un
perfil más de medio largo plazo y ahora pues quería probar otro un poco más más de intradía
así que tengo varios ya no no no no lo seguro pero puede que que hagamos el rb o puede que
hagamos el rb que tenía pensado hacer intradiliario probablemente con el dax empecemos y veremos
lo extrapolamos a más activos vale pero bueno ya no me lo toméis seguro seguro pero pero ese
es uno de los que tengo anotados para para hacer uno de revés sobre el dax me gusta mucho un futuro
que me gusta mucho vale eso sería intradía así que puede que vayamos con él el próximo día y en
todo caso casi con toda seguridad que haremos algo intradía para para entrar un poquito más en cosas
de más datos y más poquito más complejas que éstas vale amigos nada más os veo el lunes que
viene recordar enviar dudas al discord porque así las podemos compartir entre todos y creo que eso
pues añade tenerse aquí la sección de pregunta aquí para añadirlas y tratamos de responderlas
tratamos de responderlas bueno algunas aquí y otras en la clase en directo porque creo que
aportan a todos vale si alguien todavía no tiene acceso enviarnos un email con el
vuestro usuario y os lo os lo daremos nada más amigos hasta pronto que tengáis muy buena semana